SPEAKER: Testing testing
testing, this is a captioning
test.  Nicolas Geoffray
welcome back Chet Haase!
[ Applause ].
SPEAKER: Morning, from the very
much less than full room.  I
assume that people had fun at
the party last night, and that
those people are not here.
Welcome back to the conference.
So favorite things you have seen
so far?
Shout it
out.
I owe you $10.  We will make
that $5.  Motion layout, low
latency audio, the coding of C++
in the quick talk, it was braver
brave and worked out well.
And he was the DJ last night,
too.
Anything else? Custom linting,
all right.
GSI, generic system images,
lightning talks.  Did it work?
Did people have a problem with
it, no? I think the yeses win.
Sorry, we're going to ignore
you.  What are you looking
forward to today?
Well, we solved that one.  You
are beginning to regret that.
Anything else? Vitals?
Text, firesides, that will be
interesting.
All right.
Well, the only change that know
-- I know about the schedule,
there was an awkward thing with
the talk that was supposed to
happen about now.  Jake had to
go home, apparently babies,
unlike software, occasionally
shift early.
[ Laughter ].
So he made a quick departure
last night on to a plane and
went home.  We have a different
talk for you this morning on the
schedule.  Hopefully you noticed
that, if you really wanted to
see Jake, I'm going to
disappoint you and you are
welcome to see the other talk
about other screen form factors
in the other room.  Otherwise,
let me bring on the next
speakers for the next
talk.
Romain Guy.
SPEAKER: Did you call me a
disappointment? We are part of
the content section committee
for this event, and somehow we
ended up with no talk to give,
so we had to do something about
it.
SPEAKER: Unbelievably
complicated to arrange this.
His wife was in on it and it
worked out.
SPEAKER: Now we are here.
SPEAKER: And infinity we will
give a talk and there
is a team and engineers at the
team that know all about R8 and
D8, you have the opportunity to
talk about it in the Android
studio office hours, Madison in
particular, and JVG.  So check
them out, sorry, Jeffrey van
Gough in the studio area.  Ware
we're going to talk about
something completely different.
We're going to talk about trash.
Why are we going to talk about
trash? Okay, so there's a common
phrase in software, garbage
in/garbage out, but nobody ever
says how fast.  We're going to
talk about that today.  And why?
Back at I/O, we gave a talk,
modern Android development, I
have to apologize for the
glasses, the sun was right
there, annoying, couldn't see a
thing.  The glasses didn't help
and it did not make us look any
better.
So Android had certain
development practices way back
then, and Android and devices
and ecosystems have changed and
we are recommending different
practices, all the stuff you
knew about Android development
may not necessarily be true
today.  One of the things we
talked about in particular is a
lot about memory and garbage
collection, we are
recommendations there.  So for
example, we said back in the
Dalvik days, it was optimized
for size and meant to fit in a
small area, didn't have a lot of
area to do things like  like
AOT, the optimizations were not
optimal, the allocations CLEBZs
collections were expensive,
causing jank, heat fragmentation
was a problem and the
recommendation was not to
allocate anything ever if you
could possibly help it.
And use primitive types
everywhere, because objects are
expensive because you are
allocating them, avoid auto
boxing.
SPEAKER: I need to correct you.
You said avoid allocations
whenever possible? That's the
whole point.
SPEAKER: Yeah, but but
but...
but they take up space.  That is
1K to 2K? Anyway, it is
memory-related.
So the recommendation instead
was to pay attention to ART, it
turns out that ART is optimized
for performance and getting
faster with every release
because the platform was built
to opt miles -- optimize more
and more.  We do AOT, find the
hotspots, they can run faster
next time you go through the
loop.  Applications and
collections are faster, we will
go into detail about this.  We
can defragment the heat and com
PAECKT -- compact as we go, and
there's a larger object heat
that makes the allocations
faster than they used to be.  So
the recommendations are to
allocate, it is not that big of
a deal, be concerned for inner
loop situations and that you are
actually causing the device to
do stuff, you are causing
battery and CPU usage.  So you
want to be aware of these
things, but maybe they are not
such a big deal that they should
affect your APIs and your
development patterns the way
they used to.
However, that was a lot of
terse information stuffed into a
short amount of time.  We
thought, maybe we should do this
talk to explain ourselves a
little bit completely and say
why is this the case, what has
ART done to make life better?
The original idea of the talk is
we said this stuff, but would it
be nice to write dem tow o
applications and write bench
marks on this is why and these
are the canonical results that
show the premise.  That is hard,
garbage collection in ART is
concurrent, there is stuff
happening in the background all
the time.  If you want to
trigger that thing right now,
you will not be able to.  So we
made an attempt to write some
demo applications, you will see
the results here.  But we don't
have enough canonical
deterministic data to show you.
Instead, we will show you the
background of why it is
difficult to write these things
because everything is happening
magically for you in the
background.
First, we will talk about
memory.  We see a couple simple
lines of code here.  We have a
primitive type, Fu, set it to
five, we will allocate an object
here.  There are different kinds
of memory in the system and
different implications.  If we
have a primitive type, it may
show up in the stack or
registers.  Dalvik was a
register-based allocation
system, so it actually popped it
in over there. And whether it
shows up in the stack or the
register, you can think of it as
free.  It is allocated at
compiler time, it says, when I
run this line of code, here is
where I'm going to stick this
thing.  It didn't need to find
space, it knows that it has
space on the stack.  So you can
think of that as limited, sorry,
limitness storage space, as well
as the registers.  It will find
a cubbyhole to stash that thing.
It is free.  And however, when
you allocate any other, sort of,
thing, when you say new object,
then it needs to find space for
it in the heap.  That means it
needs to figure out where it is
going to fit among the other
things that already occupy the
heap and will find space down
there.  So that's the basic
memory system of runtime and the
computer overall.
So the idea of garbage
collection, well, we've all been
doing garbage collection even
before higher level languages,
like Java and Kotlin.  If you
are writing C++ code, you can do
an allocation like this, you can
write the code that uses the
object you allocated.  If you
don't do anything else, you just
leaked an object.  You are
taking up space in memory
somewhere that eventually is
going to cause you to run out of
memory.  Right? So what you need
to do is to free the object.  So
you delete the thing and reclaim
the memory, manual garbage
collection here.  Sometimes you
forget that you free it over
here and in this place you
continue using that object and
then you crash, maybe.  So very
non-deterministic system, you
are responsible for managing
your own garbage, your own
allocations and collectionsism .
Tends
to be tedious and error-prone.
We have languages
like Java, you write the
language that uses that and it
is freed.  If you continue using
it, you have a reference to this
object and that means it is
freed without freeing it too
soon.  The system knows what is
going on, you don't have to
manage this thing and scientist
it is doing it for you.  If it
is doing it for you, there are
questionings s that occur, and
there is no crash.  There are
things that occur to you, how
long does it take for the system
to do this? I know how long the
statement was going to take in
C++, how long is it going to
take for this system to
automatically find space in the
heap for me? How long does it
take to walk the heap, find the
spot, put this thing, and
allocate the space? How long duz
it take to allocate the objects,
when the reference goes away,
how long does it take to collect
these things.  And what impact
is there system-wide? When we
are returning this garbage
collector thread, this heavy
thing in the background, what
impact does that have on Jenk on
the UI thread or whatever.
And when do these things
actually happen?
And also, how efficient is that
heap usage?
Right, it is not just going to
malwick theseing CHUNCHG chunks
for the thing, it is allocating
space and sorting around.  On
Dalvik, it is fragmenting the
heap over time, you have a lot
of memory available, but you
cannot access it anymore.  So
how efficient is that and how
much memory are you taking in
the system to do all of this
stuff?
SPEAKER: We will start by
looking at how Dalvik collects
garbage.  It was the one thing
that we were using until Android
KitKat and was replaced with
ART.  So this is a picture of
the heap, everything in white is
allocated, we have a few holes,
we are trying to allocate this
blue object.  Dalvik will walk
through the heap, find a spot
where it fits, and once it finds
one, it will slide it there.
Things are more complicated when
it is time to collect objects.
So there are four phases, the
first one, Dalvik has to pause
all the threads in the
application to find the root
set.  So root sets are local
variables, threads, studied
variables.  They are just the
roots of all the allocations
that can be reached in the
application.  That takeakes a
lot of time and your application
cannot do anything.  And the
second is concurrent, the app is
running again, and from the
roots, Dalvik will find the
objects that can be reached and
will mark them as such.  And
unfortunately, since the second
phase is concurrent, the
allocations can be triggered
during that time.  So for this
instance, we are allocating
another object.  And so we need
to pause the application again
and find the reachable objects
again, all of the threads are
parsed.
And so finally, we can knock all
of the objects that are not
reachable and they are
candidates for garbage
collection and they are put into
the heap.  If we want to
allocate something in the heap
and the heap is pretty much full
and we have an object that is
marked for allocation, Dalvik
will go through the heap,
realize there is no memory
available, and will target the
file log.  Anytime you see this,
there's a log on the individual
lot cat, you can see the
messages.  So run the
collection, get to this memory,
and then we can run through the
typical allocation mechanism.
However, sometimes the heap is
full.  There are no objects that
can be collected, everyone one
is reachable, Dalvik cannot find
anything.  And two things can
happen, the heap will grow or
the application will crash.  And
it is the error you see in a lot
of applications, especially on
older devices.  This happens
when you are allocating large
objectz.  I remember a lot of
developers in the early days
find bugs against bit map
factory, because auto malware
happened during the decoding of
bit maps, and there was a link
in the factory because bit map
objects are big and it is hard
to find space for them.  There
is no leak in the factory
whatsoever.
SPEAKER: So we wrote a simple
demo application to show off how
some of this stuff with heap's
fragmentation works.  So in the
demo, we allocate chunks of
memory to max heap.  The heap
starts very small, if you cannot
allocate an object, it is going
to grow that over and over and
over until it reaches the max
possible.  So for this demo, we
allocate the 1MG chunks, there
are 400MG free, it will allocate
these chunks until it grows the
heap.  You get the error, we
catch the error, the heap is
full.
SPEAKER: This is the only
situation where you do a try
catch in the ought  out of
memory error, don't do that in
the application.
SPEAKER: Come we  -- and we say
there is 1MB free, we will
fragment the heap and free a
bunch of chunks.  We allocated
and freed every other one.
SPEAKER: Go through the
reference, set it to null, and
set it to GCU so the memory goes
away.
SPEAKER: And we get this result,
the fragmented heap size is
200MB, we have space to allocate
a 2MB object, we have 200MB
free.  So what can be the
problem? So we press the button
and it says nope, we cannot fit
that in there.  If you look at
the log, we have depressing
things here --
SPEAKER: The best error message
in all of computer science.
SPEAKER: This is beautiful.  It
says, okay, you have 200MB free
out of 400 and we're forcing a
collection so we can make room
for a 2MB chunk, we are trying
really hard to do that and we
ran out of memory.  We cannot
find space for 2MB out of 200,
because aapparently Dalvik is
bad at math.  You cannot find
them contiguous and they cannot
compact the heap.  So we cannot
shove stuff to the side to make
room for a larger object.
So ART came along in Lollipop,
it is a platform for
optimization, it no longer had
the memory constraints that
Dalvik did so they can build in
the fundamentals that they are
are improving over time.  Out of
the box, much faster allocation
times and faster run time, the
ability to do ahead of time
compilations, we are running
binary code all the time and not
jitting things to see how we can
speed things up SQULNCHLTHS  --
SPEAKER: When we talk about
faster allocation in the talk,
it is the time for the run time.
Not the constructors, it has
nothing to do with your code, it
is only in the run time itself.
SPEAKER: All right.  So how did
our allocation work?
SPEAKER: In ART, we introduced
the Rust Adock, we replaced it
for DL, which stands for dud
dley, the person that wrote it.
SPEAKER: That's what happens
when you write a nice algorithm,
people name it after you.
SPEAKER: It is the kind of
person that makes me feel
inadequate at -- as an engineer.
So it is the function call in it
the native code.  This is what
you work on in C++, the
algorithm we are using.  Dalvik
is relying on that.  And
the main benefit is we can do
thread aware, and we will look
at it in detail.  And a lot of
the tweaks that have been done,
so small allocations are grouped
together, to reduce
fragmentation, and we allow
large allocations on pages,
typically four KB on modern OS
and gives you better
performance.
And the garbage
collector has to collect logs.
And overall,
allocations are four to five
times faster.  You can do
something really really really
expensive in your constructor
and you are still five times
faster than dlmalloc.
SPEAKER: And the other very
important thing with ART is the
ability to deal with large
objects in a better way.  So you
have this normalize object, it
will find space for it in the
heap over here.  And what
happens if you have this large
object, we mean an array of
primitives or string.
And these are the types chosen
because we can guarantee these
objects will not have a
reference to something else.
They can live on their
own.
SPEAKER: 12KB.
SPEAKER: That's the heuristic
for now, right now it is 12K,
the primitive types are string.
Where would we put this? In
Dalvik, we put it where exactly?
In this fragmented heap, there
is no space.  In ART, it is
simpler.  The
complicated mechanism looks like
this, we shove it like this, we
malloc a space in there and
shove it in.
We allocate a space in there,
you are part of the heap, and it
is living on its own somewhere.
Very fast, very easy.
And it is also a moving
collector, so we can actually
compact things.
And so we no longer have the
fragmentation problem.  However,
it does this in the
background.
So it is more complicated.  My
understanding was that if your
application goes into the
background, then eventually this
very expensive operation, it can
take up to 100MS, can compact
the heap.  We don't want to run
it in the fore ground, we are
going to Jenk your app, we will
wait until it is in the
background, the user is doing
something else, not paying
attention, we are compacting the
heap for you.  I will show the
same fragmentation crash error,
I will show how it crashes on
KitKat using dav -- Dalvik and
it will crash on the releases
until we can do it in the fore
ground in a later release in O.
And this was a cool demo, ran it
on L, and it didn't crash.  It
will defrag in the background,
but also in the fore ground if
it has to.  That's what you
want.  So if you need that
memory now,p  wouldn't it be
nice if it doesn't crash?
SPEAKER: And this is a
replacement for the GC file log
from before.
SPEAKER: And it says you need
space for this large object, we
will compact things and then put
it a where we need to.  So on L
and above, we run the same
fragmentation
demo, we malloc to the maximum
heap size, one MB free, and then
we try to find space for the 2MB
block, compact the heap, and it
puts it in.
Very simple.
SPEAKER: So another improvement,
so remember with the Dalvik GC,
we had two phases, including two
pauses for your application.
The pauses water  were bad
because it was not doing
anything at that time.  And what
is worse, the pauses can be
expensive.  So on average, some
of the two pauses were two
milliseconds.  And even when it
was 10, it was pretty good.  We
have done a lot of performance
work over the year and I have
seen these pauses work sometimes
over 100 milliseconds.  So no
matter how good the UI is, it
will Jenk.  If the user is
trying to scroll, it is not
going to work well.  So one of
the things that ART does, it
removes one of the pauses.  So
the first step, the marking the
root set, finding the roots that
are reachable in the heap St. A
concurrent phase.  It doesn't
pause the application anymore.
And the other pause we have left
is a lot faster.  Instead of 10
milliseconds, we have 3 mill
milliseconds.  It will pause,
and if GCT happens during
scrolling, you can reach 60FPS
without Jenk.
What was introduced in ART is
the concept of the fast
collection of the young
generation, keep track of the
objects that were allocated
since the last major garbage
collection, those are temporary
objects, and we look at them
first.  If we allocate memory by
looking at the subject first
because they are short-lived, we
don't go through the heap.
SPEAKER: This has an important
implication for Android
development, all of a sudden, we
made object allocation and
collection much easier.
SPEAKER: It is not free, just
less expensive.
SPEAKER: Yes.
SPEAKER: We will introduce the
heap that we talked about, you
have less fragmentation.  And
one of the benefits of that,
because we don't fragment the
heap, we don't have to grow the
heap as much in all the
processes.  And of course, we
don't have
the GCFORALLOC and the faster
run time, and we can reduce the
GPAC which has nothing to do
with the garbage collector.
Marshmallow, I was joking
yesterday that it is a boring
release, I cannot remember what
was Marshmallow.  Here it is,
optimizations.
SPEAKER: Things got faster.
Fine-grain details, things got
faster.
N, things got faster, allocation
in particular, they rewrote all
the thing, the cool stuff in
assembly, and that still helps s
in software.  Now we are up to
10 times faster in allocation
costs when you compare it to
Dalvik.
And now we are in Oreo, they
rewrote the whole thing.  We
introduced the concurrent heap
compaction collector, and we can
compact in the fore ground, not
just when we do the GC for Alloc
in the space, but it is moving
stuff around and optimizing what
the heap looks like so
allocations are faster and
easier over all.  So
defragmentation in the fore
ground, you are not resizing the
heap as often because the heap
is always -- we are culling the
things out of it.  There are
fewer GCs FORALLOC because we
are not in the situation.  So
what about the applications and
services in the fore ground?
System, play, UI.  We cannot
defragment those until it is in
a bad situation.  Wouldn't it be
nice to be in the fore ground so
those are optimized? If we can
do it for them, we are getting
system-wide savings on the heap
size for all of those
applications.  Smaller heaps for
all means less memory.  And the
entire device had a 30 percent
savings on memory requirements.
And so we can take a look at how
compaction works.  In general,
we have these two 56K buckets
that are assigned per thread.
That means again, huge savings
in not having to lock down all
the threads to do the
allocations in collections.  A
thread, if it needs memory, it
is responsible for itself.
So a thread says, okay, I need
memory, it is handed one of
these buckets, it allocated it
in there.  And over time, the
thing is defragmented, there's a
heuristic if it is less than 70
or 75 percent utliization, we
can collect it and empty it.  So
we see the T1-3 regions here, we
don't have a lot going on here.
We can take the memory in there,
all of the allocations and shove
them somewhere else in the heap,
empty out the buckets, and that
allows something that is super
efficient, thread local bump
allocatur.  And all we have to
do is move the pointer.  We
don't have to walk the heap to
find where the free space it, we
put the next object in the next
available space and we know
where that is according to the
pointer.  It turns out all of
this stuff put together, we are
now 18 times faster than Dalvik
for these allocations.  So we
can see how these allocations
work in practice.  You can see
all of these little colored
objects, we are making space for
them in the different threads
that need these allocations.  In
T1, we zeoed it out and we
advance the pointer, the pointer
tells us where to put the next
one and the one after that and
so on.  Very fast and easy
compared to what we were doing
before.  On the graph, you can
see the comparison of where we
were at with Dalvik in
allocation costs, depending on
in O, with bump pointer and
assembly allocations
instead.
Where are we going now? It is
important to note that the young
generation stuff that we talked
about as being so awesome is
currently gone.
SPEAKER: But it is in O stream.
It will be in the future
release.
SPEAKER: So there are trade offs
here, we believe it is better
overall.  All of the benefits
you get from the garbage
collector and O compensates for
the older not being there.  Look
for those in a future release.
SPEAKER: And object pools, this
is a technique that we have
recommended using in the past,
we use it ourselves extensively
inside the platform.  The wisdom
is reusing an object has to be
faster than allocating and
collecting them all the time.
You can see the performance
graphs, the X axis is the size
of the object that you are
creating or using.  And in red,
it is the time it takes to
handle the objects with the
pool, and to allocate and
collect the objects.  And until
N, using a pool is basically
always a win compared to the
garbage collector.
But with O, we all the
implements we've done and this
thread allocator, synchronized
pools of objects are generally
slower.
And if you have a pool of object
that is only on one thread, that
thread only, you are actually
doing the positioning that ART
does for you in O   You might
not see those savings.  In O,
you should have a synchronized
pool of object and you are
probably better off without the
pool.
SPEAKER: And there's a certain
memory size of object where
these graphs cross.  This is in
a benchmark application that is
hammering it and maximizing the
bandwidth.  So the general
advice is that you really
shouldn't use that, especially
the synchronized pool approach,
because A, it is error-prone and
tedious to manage, and B, it is
slower in general.  That
synchronization access tends to
be slow e er than what we can do
now.
SPEAKER: The point of O is we
don't have the lock in anymore
for the allocations.
SPEAKER: So, what are the
recommendations now? Creating
garbage is okay.
I wouldn't go out of your way to
create garbage, it is still
taking time.  You are requiring
us to take time to allocate
objects as well as later collect
them.  And you are taking up
battery and CPU and you are
causing --
SPEAKER: And don't do that,
Chet, you should see his desk.
It is pretty disgusting.
SPEAKER: I like to be a counter
example.  Creating this stuff is
okay, and so is collecting it.
Use the types and the objects
that you need F. It makes sense
for the architecture, the APIs,
for the libraries for the code,
use those.  We are not pushing
everyone to use end to end bit
flags everywhere.  Instead, go
ahead and alCAILT icate when you
need to for the use case.
However, GC is overhead.
SPEAKER: We will demo that that
showcases that.
SPEAKER: And make the right
choices for you.
And, in general, the framework
programmers, we still are your
interloop.  So we still take the
old practices, because why would
we allocate if we didn't need to
if we can make your inner loop
faster.  So be aware of the
inner loop situations,
otherwise, it  do the right
thing for your code.
Wrote a simple application to
showcase the Jenk you can see
because of allocations and
collections.
During the on-draw I would
call out to a method to run some
stuff.
And, in this case, we're going
to test auto boxing.  So we have
an array of 100,000 float object
objects, capital F.  It is not
the primitive float, it is the
capital F, we are allocating
these objects on-the-fly.  This
is what the method looks like
that runs on every frame, walks
the length of the array and
takes a primitive float and
stuffs it into the array that
causes an auto box, so these
tiny allocations goes into the
array.  A lot of them over time,
because of the auto boxing
thing, it is going to cause a
bunch of allocations and we need
to collect them over time as
well.
So, if we take a look at the
demo.  We will pop out.
All right.
So we're
running on K here, run this
animation, we should take a look
at the log here.
We run the auto box, we are
coming -- calling out to the
method.  If you look at the log,
so we are taking allocation
times of 28, 24, sort of in
general, high-20s milliseconds
and we're causing a lot of GC,
because that is what happens
when you do this thing.  We can
pause this, pop over and see
what it looks like on O, run the
animation here.  We enable the
log for O.
We do the auto boxing, and zoom
in on this.  And the allocation
times are obviously much less
than they were before, and also
more importantly, there are no
GC FOR ALLOCS.  We are not
triggering the
Jenk-inducing ALLOC in this
case.  There's something similar
for bit maps.
We will look at the KitKat log.
In this, you are allocating bit
maps.  Again, we're getting a
lot of Jenk there.  If we zoom
in on the log, the allocations
for these large objects, a
thousand by a thousand bit map,
you are taking in 12 or then
milliseconds each time and you
are constantly triggering these
GC FOR ALLOCs because you need
to make memory for the new one.
If you pop over to the O log, we
will stop this, go over here on
the animation, do the bit map
test, and now we have allocation
times of, well, zero, 1.
Because again, all that it is
doing is an Malloc, shoving it
in and it is easy to allocate
and collect when it needs it.
Stop that.
All right.
This is the bit map test,
allocating a thousand by a
thousand bit map.  You can see
the results that we did.
SPEAKER: All right.
So this is a demo to stress test
to the garbage collector and see
what overhead we get.  This is a
ray tracer using rendering that
I --
SPEAKER: You can tell it is a
rendering because it is a
checker board.
SPEAKER: That's right.  And I
brought it over to Android.  I
will not run you through the
code, but this is Kotlin, and it
does a lot of allocations.  I
have a data class, it contains
three floats, XYZ, those are
primitives.  Not the capital F
objects from Java.  I observed
the hundreds of lines of code.
It is math on the object, we
have float equal X, we do
division and additions.  And the
way these functions are
implemented might float through
is immutable.  Every time I add
or multiply, I create a new
object.  So these are small
objects and for every pixel to
render, we have hundreds of
thousands or millions of these
3s.  So we exercise the GC.  We
create two system images, one on
KitKat, one on O, both running
on the emulator, running the
same hardware, on Nexus, with
the same number of cores and the
host machine.  The difference is
the garbage collector.  And what
I will press next, both demoes
will run at the same time.  At
the top is O, bottom is KitKat.
See if you can spot the
difference in performance.
It takes 47 seconds for KitKat
to render the first dial.
SPEAKER: But it is a good dial.
SPEAKER: And we are running the
exact same application, the
difference is the garbage
collector.
So on O, rendering one dial
takes 100 to 500MS, and on K, it
takes 40 to 50 seconds.  So two
orders of magnitude slower.  If
we look at the logs on KitKat,
this is what you see.  A bunch
of GC file logs, and I grabbed
logs for 10 seconds' worth of
computations.  You can see that
we are constantly stopping all
the threads and blocking the
applications all the time.
Nothing is getting done.
That's a lot of GCs, and you can
see every time the GC takes 3 to
5 milliseconds.
So if we can look at systrace on
O, even though things are
better, they are not quite
perfect.
So this is sys trace here, you
can see what the CPUs are doing.
And from the far, it looks like
they are busy.  They have few
worker threads that are are
computing this 3D scene.
There's a lot of cases where the
CPUs are not doing anything,
there are holes in the pipe.
So if we look at the app
itself, we see two interesting
things.
We have the threads that are
doing the work, and from time to
time, the pause, and you can
probably not read this, but it
is full suspend check and you
are not doing any computation.
And the reason is that we have
this thread, the heap test
demon.  It is the concurrent
garbage collector.  So even
though we are doing garbage
collection and allocating so
many orbital smany objects, it
takes so much timetime.  It is
blocking anyway.
It is not pausing because we
have to pause them, it is not
for the algorithms, because the
GC is still busy.
And I was running more threads
and running into rough situation
situationssituations, I had so
many threads that they are
starting the GC thread.  And as
a result, we are only getting
about 30 to 40 percent CPU
utliization.  We don't have all
the power on the device.  So
what you saw on O is three times
faster than that, if it was not
allocating as much.
And so one of the things we will
talk about, we have four minutes
left.  You have to be careful
when you create benchmarks,
because the garbage collector
can affect the results of your
benchmark once, well, not really
the benchmark itself, but the
algorithm you are benchmarking.
Once it is inside the
application, it behaves
differently.  I will skip this.
With  when you have a CPU, you
have the gold cores.  And everyb
core has a nil 1 cache, every 2
core, and there's an L3 cache
shared by all the cores.  When
you want to access data, I have
a float array.  The first time
we assess the float, the CPU
looks at the L1 cache, sees if
it is there, goes to the L 2, if
it is not there then to the L3
and the program.  And it is more
and more expensive as you go up
the chain.  So the L1 takes a
new nano seconds, 2 is 4 times
that amount, 3 is 10 times
slower, and so on.
And I wrote a demo that
allocates the list
of flow arrayarrays.  Each is
16MB, represented by the red
lines, and I built a benchmark
using that.  If I look at all of
those arrays of floats, this is
what it looks like in RAM.  They
are neatly stacked together in
RAM, and I'm using a width of 64
bytes here for a reason we will
see in a minute.  And then I
wrote a simple algorithm, I go
through the array, I wrote
computations, we will see what
happens to memory.  So when we
access the first float array in
the list, it is not in the
cache, it is in the RAM, and/or
L1, or the 2 or 3.
And they are not going to
fetch only one byte, but 64
bytes at a time.  By fetching
the first array, we fetch the
next three at the same time.
So when I want to read the
arrays, nothing happens because
they are in the L1 cache.
So this is pretty efficient.
And then we run our computation.
And in the test app, I have the
initialization of the arrays so
we can allocate other stuff.
And I'm doing this to basically
replicate what happens when the
GC moves things around or you
have fragmentation in the app,
and for any number of reasons
that you are seen before, they
are not next to one another in
RAM.  So I'm representing this
with a bunch of gray lines.  If
you run the algorithm again, we
fetch the first array.  And
instead of fetching the other
did I tell  data that we want,
it is put in the L1.  And in the
next array, it is not in the L1,
we have to go back to memory and
get it.  We are running the same
algorithm, but now we have to do
more.  The CPU has to do more
work.
And we can re-create the same
thing by spacing out the arrays
more so we will not find them in
the L2 or L3 and force the CPU
to do more work.  If we run the
different variants of the
algorithm, all we did is change
the way we alquate the objects,
running the same computations.
When everyone is stored together
in RAM, the algorithm takes
about 150 milliseconds on the
pixel thread.  That the no
thresh.  And when I space out
the allocations so we cannot
find the data we want in the L1,
we almost twice as slow and
running the same computations,
but the CPU is busy and fetching
data in RAM.  If I space out the
computations more so we find it
in the L2, it is 5 times slower.
The same exact algorithm.  So if
you write benchmarks, that is
really good.  You should
probably do that.  Be very
careful, be aware of the fact
that the numbers getting to
benchmark might be very
different than the numbers you
get in the app running on your
user's devices.
And, yeah, you are actually
benchmarking the CPU access
patterns.
And with that, we are done.  We
have six seconds left.
SPEAKER: Very important thing,
if you are interested in what we
talked about today, it there's a
deeper version of this as well
as the runtime improvements by
engineers on the ART team.  So
check that out, it is at the
same time as the fireside chat
at 11:10.  Please go and see
that talk as well.  And that's
it.  Thank you.
SPEAKER:
Thanks.
SPEAKER: [ Applause ]
.
Coming up next: Use Android Text
Like a Pro by Siyamed Sinir.
GZ
name is Siyamed Sinir, I work on
Android text.  And today, I
would like to talk about why
improving your text measurement
performance is important for
your overall apps performance.
In order to do this, I wanted to
gather some numbers and,
therefore, I wrote a simple
sample app that has a feed and
is similar to the applications
we use every day.  It has a list
of items, image, and some text.
And when we look at the text, as
you can see in the picture, the
user name and the title for each
feed item is what we call single
style text.  And the content
contains a text that has
different colors, text sizes,
fonts, etc.
One important point here that
I would like to emphasize, on
our platform right now, the
hyphenation is turned on by
default.  However, in this app,
as you can see, there is no
identificationation applied --
identificationation applied, and
Android runs in correct words
side by side, it cannot do any
hyphenation.  So when you look
at each feed item, it has a very
simple structure, a linear layer
at top, the image layer, and
fields for title and content.
I'm pretty sure it is the same
or similar to one of your app's
existing design or layout
structure.
And what I wanted to see was,
for each field item, what is the
percentage of the time spent on
text versus the whole layout.
So what I did, I wrote a
benchmark where I called the
linear layout measure, on one
end, and meanwhile I recorded
all the parameters that were
passed to the different text
fields, and I assimilated the
same thing on those text fields.
Because of the layout here, the
TextViews at the top were
getting two calls
each.
In order to have consistent
numbers or
And just turning the hyphenation
off, and turning off hyphenation
did not have any affect on the
UI.  Finally, I wanted to check
how the had beenumbers would
improve, if I wanted a new API
that I added on Android P and
AndroidX, for computed text.
These numbers were crazy, 4
milliseconds becomes 20X.  It is
almost a 2X improvement.
And now I want to describe how
predicted text
works.
I want to show what kind of
things we did while doing the
computed text.  We asked
questions, like why text
measurement is so expensive, and
since almost at the beginning,
we did the text performance, and
as you understand from the
number, 98, it is always going
to be a bottleneck.  Therefore,
we tried to see, can we move all
of it and provide an API.  And
when the system calls measure on
text field, it does the
preliminary work and identifies
the width and height of the text
edit it contains and according
to the parameters that are
passed to on measure, and the
numbers that it finds, it
creates a layout.  All of these
processes goes into our native
code.  Because we have to use
some open source libraries such
as
freetype to measure our text.
And 90 percent of our time is
spent on the native code.
And when we process a string
like this to our native code,
what it does is it divides it
into words, and then for each
word, it applies text shaping.
It finds the font that can
render the collector and tries
to bring those collectcollectors
in the work together.  And then
we check out much time this
takes, compared to all the time
that is spent on the native
code.  It is again more than 90
percent.  So text measurement,
taking the 90 percent of the old
measurement, native code taking
ninety percent of the text, and
shaping taking more than 90
percent of the native code means
that most of the measurement
time for this app is spent on
text shaping.
The system applies to the same
rules for all of the words, for
each word that is measured, it
caches them.
One of the reasons to cache them
is, just after the measure or
layout, there will be a draw
operation, and the draw will
need the
same information.
Then it applies line breaking
and identif hyphenation.  Some
one question here is, why does
hyphenation, turning it off,
improve the performance twice?
It is mainly because of,
whenever it tries to hyphenate,
it has to apply text shaping for
more words.
Let's say that, in here, it the
the example is divided into X
and ample.  It has to do two
more shaping on two more words.
So the next creation is, if we
were to move this expansive
measurement background thread,
what we would need.  The first
issue we encountered was, before
P, was acquiring giant
synchronization locks.  We fixed
it on Android P, we made it  the
locks smaller.  Can we use the
layout classes for such a goal?
There were two issues.  Layout
classes needed a width to be
provided to them so they can do
their calculations.  And that
width, you would not have that
width before measuring.  So it
was a chicken and egg problem.
The other one is the layout
objects are just reprints for
the text it contains, like a
cache on the Java site, and they
don't know about the previously
calculated layout objects, they
know how many legss layers there
are, the start and end, and the
coordinates.
So we wondered, what if we
created the construct? First of
all, it doesn't need a width.
Second, it should be able to
create it on a background
thread safely. And it needs
strong references to the native
layout word objects. This is
important, in terms of layout,
if you were to create a layout,
before you need it, then maybe
when it is time to measure or
render it, you will use the
layout objects, they will be in
the cache and there was no far
guarantee you would have steady
improvement.
We wanted to extend this
construct, because with  we want
it to be compatible with the
current APIs and also your
applications.
Since it is mostly interested in
how the text will look, this
construct needed some parameters
that will change the next
styling, such as the text size,
color, local,
and etc.
One important thing is, that
was the reason why previously
those native objects were being
cached and edited.  And it is
the amount of memory that they
use.
And right now, when we use
PrecomputedTextPrecomputedText,
you spend 20KB for 500
characters.
Even though it is spanable,
with a mutable interface, every
calculation that the text does
is done at the construction
type.  You should
not be calling set span or
remove span functions, with
styling information that will
change how the text will look,
otherwise you will get an
exception.  That will invalidate
all of the computation and it
will be useless.
And then we look at the
parameters that PrecomputedText
required.  Since most of the
text styling information is
right now encapsulated in the
text pane, it requires the text
pane as a mandatory constructor
argument.  The others are break
strategy and text direction you
will know from the static layout
builder.
You will be designing the text
styling in the XML, you want the
helper function where you can
create the PrecomputedText
parameters using the text field.
However, at this point, I would
like to emphasize that TextView
is not required to create a
PrecomputedText per am, it is a
helper function, and it will
make more sense when we go over
how to use PrecomputedText with
RecyclerView.
Since version 25, re
RecyclerView has a prefetch
feature.  And not only during on
the unbind folder, you will call
set text and the recycle view
will measure the whole layout
that you just created.  And we
know that the measurement part
of the TextViews are expensive.
When you use RecyclerView with
PrecomputedText, you will change
set text to set text
feature, and what
PrecomputedText will do, before
the item is shown on the screen,
go to the background thread, do
the text measurement and it will
show the PrecomputedText.  And
when the computation is ready,
it will switch back to the right
thread and it will call set text
with this PrecomputedText that
makes the measurement part much
faster than the
previous case.
SPEAKER: You just change it to
be set text feature and some
configuration for para computed
text.  And here, what you tell
the system, please run this task
on the background thread, and
para compute my text with this
sequence, my data, and this
display configuration
configuration.  And this becomes
very handy to complete the para
computed text per ams.
And one point here, if you are
changing the text styling
according to the data you have,
you have all of the spanables
before calling
this function.
So you can turn off hyphenation
in your app globally.  This is
simple, and you saw the affect,
it increases the measurement
performance by 2X.  And first,
we define a new style and turn
off hyphenation for that style.
We use the my bails style for
load cases, and in version 21,
we extend the base TextView
style from the
material.textview.  And finally,
on your team, you set Android
TextView style to be your
new style.
And before I summarize, I will
turn off hyphenation in your app
globally so your measurement can
be faster.  And it is not only
going to be a text measurement,
the whole screen measurement,
depending on how much text you
have, will be almost twice as
much faster.  And then, please
check the PrecomputedText API,
and if you are using
RecyclerView, please apply the
PrecomputedText and RecyclerView
prefetch code that I showed to
you so you get a more smooth
scrolling experience for your
users.
This is my talk, thank you very
much for
listening.
Coming up next: Files for Miles:
Where to Store Them All? By Jeff
Sharkey SPEAKER: Hey, everyone,
I'm Jeff Sharkey, I'm a software
engineer on the framework team,
and we're going to be digging
into files on Android and all of
the places that Android gives
you to store those files.  So
today we will start by looking
at common locations that Android
offers.
The first broad category is
internal storage.  And this
storage can be classified as
safe and secure, because it is
something that the Android OS
protects and part of the
application sandbox model we
offer.  You have probably
covered these directories
before, like context file, it is
a great place
to store things.
We will get into get cash dir,
and the file space is not
counted against the application.
Android reserves the right to go
in there and delete the files if
the user needs the disk space
elsewhere.  It is a trade off
and a two-way street.  Another
directory, get- no back up files
dir, if you want to migrate
between devices.  It is a great
-- if the device goes through a
back up and a restore phase,
those files in the directory,
they will thought  not be
carried across the back up.  You
can use it for that.
And finally, get code cash dir,
for jitted and optimized code.
It will delete under two
conditions, when the application
is updated via Play Store, or
whenever the OS itself has an
upgrade, from the release to the
pre-release, it will clear the
directory.  And another broad
category of locations is
external storage.  When we think
of that, it is more of a shared
area and it is unprotected.
And the reason I just
mention that is data showed in
that location, you may write it
there, and other applications
can request the storage
permission on Android and they
can write the data or modify it
without you knowing about it.
So it is something that we
definitely discourage storing
sensitive contents in that
location.  If you need to store
data there, consider finding a
way to prevent and to verify the
integrity of that data if you
need to trust it.  The
directories here, similar to
internal storage.  External
media dirs are scanned by media
store on the device.  It is a
good place to store photos or
videos included in the user's
gallery application.  Get
OBBDIRS, OBB stands for opaque
binary blocks, they are large
blocks for Google Play.  And
data in those locations are
counted toward the app's code
size rather than data size.  So
far, we have talked about
internal and external storage.
And these are all great places
for you to store data that
belongs to your app.  Be but you
might find yourself creating
data that belongs to the user
that the user may want to store
in a different location.  And
that's a great place to use the
storage access framework.
And there are two intents that
work great there, intent action
open document and create
document.  These have been
around in the platform since the
KitKat release, you can think of
them as an open and a saved
dialogue box for the user.  It
really offers a great
experience, because the user has
control over exactly where those
files are stored on the device.
It givesthem the freedom to
choose any of those locations,
and opens the door for cloud
storage for  providers.  You
don't have to integrate an SDK,
you can launch the intent and
the user can select where they
want the file to be stored.
There are great talks, I
encourage you to search around
online, there is great content
that goes more in depth.  We
talked about basic locations,
let's do a deep dive on two
scientific advanced locations
today.  One is direct boot, and
the second we will dig into is
cached data.  The first is
direct boot that you may not
have encountered before.  And it
is worth starting out, we built
the direct boot feature to solve
an important problem.  When
before the end release, when we
encrypted an Android device, if
the user re-booted it, no apps
can run until the user entered
their credentials, a pin, a
pattern, and password.  In the
end releases, we created two
storage areas, they are
encrypted but with two different
keys.  And we call these areas
the device protected area and
the credential protecteded area.
The device protected area is
available by virtue of the
device proving it has not been
tampered with.  When the device
boots up, it verifies it has not
been tampered with and unlocked
the protected storage.  When the
user enters the pin, pattern, or
password, it is available for
applications to use.  If you
have not encountered these APIs
before, all of your data by
default as an app developer is
stored in a credential-protected
area.  If you find a place where
you would like to run before the
user has unlocked their device,
that is where it might be useful
to store small bits of
information out in that
device-protected area so that
your app can be useful while the
device is locked.  And then you
might ask the question, how do
you gain access to the storage
area?
Context.get-files.dir offers
that's area.  And there's a
method on context, create device
protected storage context,
that's a little bit of a
mouthful.  It returns another
different context where the file
APIs, referring to internal
storage, on that returned
context point at the device
protected storage.  So let's
take a look at some code
examples of how you might
integrate with those APIs.  If
you want to become device
direct-boot aware, is to think
about what data you want to keep
on credential protected storage
or migrated.  So a lot of you
are writing code like this,
during the initial upgrade step,
how to migrate data back and
forth.  The first thing you will
do in starting the application
is to ask, is the user unlocked?
Has the pin, pattern, or
password been offered? So you
can check, is the current user
unlocked? Assuming they are,
that means you have access to
the device and the credentialed
storage. And here, you can see
there are two move methods at
helpers.  You can move the
preferences and databases back
and forth.  The reason we
provide these helper methods is
often times shared preferences
and databases can actually be
made up of multiple files on
disk and some of that data may
be cached in memory.  By calling
the helper methods, we ensure
that all of the data is moved
and any in-memory caches are not
invalidated along the way.  When
you think about data you want to
migrate, one thing we say is
only move the data you need to
provide the user experience
while the device is locked.  So
if you are building the alarm
clock app, we will move the
user's next alarm time into that
device-protected area to make
sure that the alarm clock will
go off if the user's device is
currently locked.  Another
strategy, if you have
off-tokens, we recommend that
people create a second type of
authtoken for your full server.
One ask a full access token, we
recommend keeping that in the
credential-protected area and
creating a simple, limited in
scope token auth token and only
storing that in the device
protected area.  And maybe when
it talks to your server in the
back end, it has three messages
and cannot do operations beyond
that.  It gets the user's
experience when you need to,
without accessing the richer
information in the cloud.  So we
have talked, if it is unlocked,
we can migrate data back and
forth.  And the else clause
here, there's a run time
broadcast that is here, for user
unlocked, to run the code when
the user enters that pin,
pattern, or password.
And the middle code snippet
here, the move methods, they
work in both directions.  If you
move the data out into the
device proteched  protected
area, you can move it into the
credentialed area.  And on the
bottom of the screen, if you are
wondering if a particular file
is going to be encrypted at REST
by the operating system, you can
quickly check for that as well.
There's a storage manager, is
encrypted API.  That can be
helpful when you are rollering
rolling your own encryption.
And the second dive is cached
data on the OS.  This is data
that you can regenerate or
redownload later on if it
happens to be deleted.  This is
a two-way street, the OS will
not count the data that you use
in that area against the app,
but we reserve the right to
delete that data if the user
needs the disk space for
something else they are doing.
Something we improved in the O
release, we rewrote the
algorithms used internally.  A
big question we got from you,
from developers, is how much
cached space is appropriate to
use? Can I use 500MB, is that
too much, is 50MB too much? Now
we offer explicit guideguidance.
There's an API to figure out a
cached quota for your
application, that the device
thinks is reasonable for the app
to use.  And it adjusts it over
time.  If the user spends a lot
of time in the application, we
will increase the number so you
can offer a better user
experience to your users.
And another thing we did in the
O release, we rewrote the
implementation of how that data
is cleared.  Before the O
release, we list all of the
cached files on the OS, sort
them by modified time and delete
the oldest files.  There are
ways to gameify the system, by
setting the time out to the year
2038.  So we fixed that.  In O
and future releases, the OS will
delete data fromp appessibility
Partners s most over the the
quota first.  If your app is in
the cached quota that the OS
recommended, you can be
confident that the data is there
and will remain available as the
user starts filling up their
disk.
And soso let's look at code
snippets.  If you are
integrating with a common class,
it is easy to connect the two
things together.  We can ask for
the recommended cached quota
bytes and plug it in to trim how
much size it is using.  If you
have multiple types of caches,
it is up to you to decide how
you want to fractionally account
or distribute the cache against
the internals of your app.  The
second code snippet, if you are
rolling your own caching,
there's get cache size bytes, a
fast way to ask the question,
how much cached space the app is
using.  It is an optimized call
that will return and
it should  it is faster than you
iterating over the disk usage to
figure out how much space you
are using.
And another feature of the O
release is the ability to have
cached bihaviors.  We heard from
developers that it is useful,
you may download multiple files,
it should be treated as a unit
or a group.  You can download a
movie and a sub titles file that
goes with it.  If you store both
in the cached directly, if one
of them is deleted, the other
file is not useful and valuable.
So the cached behavior allows
you to tell us, as the OS, if we
need disk space, we should
delete both of these at the same
time.  So we talked about the
common storage locations, we
will talk about how we can work
together, both the OS helping
you as developers.  And the
biggest thing we offered in the
O release is helping you get the
disk space that you need.
Before the O release, in if you
wanted to do a large download,
and if you looked at the free
disk space, you may only see
500MB for free.  It may look
like the download was
impossible.  There is a new a.m.
tin the  API in the O release,
it will delete cached files for
the operation to succeed in the
application.  If there isn't
enough disk space, there are new
intents to launch to get the
user involved, to pick items and
things they can do to help free
up the disk space.  How to use
the API? The very top of the
slide, this is a way that you
are writing code today.  You
will do a simple check, a
download size, Java.I/O.file/get
usable space.  That's an
operation that looks like it is
not possible to succeed.  If you
convert the code using the
snippet on the slide, if you
call storage manager.get
allocated bytes.API, it will
return not just the free space,
but the space that the OS is
willing to free up on your
behalf.  So in this case it may
look like, if we have enough
space, we can actually open the
file output stream and now there
is an API, allocate bytes.  And
this will actually claim that
disk space for your application,
deep underneath, it will use the
F allocate system call to make
sure that the blocks
belong to the application and
you have the space guaranteed to
you.
And the else block here, if
there is not enough space, we
can ask the user for help to
free up the disk space.
Sharing content, we covered this
before.  How can we work
together there? Use content URIs
when you are sharing between
applications, never use file U
RRBS  RIs.  In sharing the
application, you do not have the
permissions that you need to
access the files on disk.  If
you use content URIs, the OS can
make sure that they can open the
content.  If you find yourself
in this position, the file
provider is a great way to
convert between the two with a
single line of code, every place
to convert from file to content.
And over the years, because this
is an important thing to pay
attention to, we built strict
mode APIs to detect these places
in your app where you are
accidentally sharing file URIs
and in a more recent release,
you can detect where you are
sharing a content URI and you
are forgetting the read or right
to go along with that intent.
Those are two URIs that are
helpful to look at.
And native code, that is another
area to think about.
And we strongly recommend that
you look at opening files up in
higher-level managed code, in
Java or Kotlin, and passing the
file descriptor down into the
native code.  Opening a managed
code gives the OS an opportunity
to notice, inspect, and correct
things.  It can look for strict
mode violations.  If you open up
the managed code, it may notice
that the thread you are running
on is causing a block or Jenk in
your app.  We are going to start
using this more in future
Android release sreleases.  So
open the file in
Java, past the integer, to the
code.  Don't move it past the
file itself.  And you can do
this with parcel file
descriptor, you can open up the
file on disk, for read/write,
and there's detach FD that
returns the integer that is
ready to cross against the J&I
boundary.
And another method that is a tip
or trick that is useful.  If you
find yourself crossing against
J&I to do a handful of system
calls, look at
Android.system.OS, there are
several calls for you to use in
Java today.  We added that a
couple releases ago, so you may
be able to FIMEGD  find that you
can do the sis calls in Java and
you can get rid of the J&I in
the application.
SPEAKER: And working with media,
we recommend that you use media
store if you are looking to find
the files on your device.  You
might be tempted to build your
own index, that can be wasteful
in terms of CPU and battery for
the user. And we are working on
improving media store and really
adding functionality there.  So
stay tuned over the next couple
releases.  And another note,
open files, open the content of
the media through content
resolver.  There are columns
across the operating system
called _ data, they return a raw
system file path.  You may
notice that a couple of the _
data columns have been
deprecated in previous releases.
That is going to continue, you
may notice those columns
deprecated over time.  We want
people to merge over to content
URIs as a best practice.  Thank
you for your time, in digging
into the nitty-gritty areas of
storage. I will be in the Q&A
storage after if you have
equations -- questions for me.
Thank you for your time.
[ Applause ]
Coming up next: Deep Dive into
the ART Runtime by Nicolas
Geoffray, David Sehr.
.
SPEAKER: Everyone, the next
session will begin in 10
minutes.
SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
I'm Nicholas from the Android
platform team, thanks for being
here.  I'm impressed that there
are people showing up.  The
Android fireside chat was kind
of scaring me, everyone just
avoided
the session.
It is great to have you here,
this talk is about ART.  There's
a change in the schedule this
morning, you may have attended
Chet's talk.  Who went to Chet's
talk?
Okay.
How was it, was it good?
Yeah, were you excited?
18X, allocation
times?
So there's a part of this talk,
that was supposed to be on
garbage collection, and my
colleague, David, was planning
on giving. But we are not going
to re-hash the same thing.
So I will put long pauses,
awkward ones, I hope, during the
talk so I can fit it to 40
minutes.  So bear with me.
So, given that we're celebrating
10 years of Android, I thought
it would be a good idea to think
about what we've done the last
10 years, and how the Android
run time, the thing that we
worked on for a couple of years
now evolved.  So here we
are.
So some of you went to Chet's
talk, so I guess you already
know what an Android runtime is
in the Android stack.  But in
case you don't, it is the little
layer here between the Android
framework, the Android operating
system, and the actual
underlying Kernel.
The runtime runs both the
Android framework, and all the
apps, so everything between Java
that we
execute.
And being core in the platform,
it is responsible for a ton of
things, like the user experience
could be very bad if the run
time was more efficient.  You
saw it this morning with how the
GC was sort of, kind of, poor in
the
Dalvik days.
I will show you that the
runtime versions, the itRAISHZ
itRAISHZ -- iterations over the
past, what do we need to improve
for this year? Like I said, ART
runtime is possible for a bunch
of things.  And role performance
is one clear one, how fast we
can execute Java code.  And
clearly, it is also responsible
for Jenk, the 16 milliseconds
window, if the runtime is not
able to execute the Java code of
the app, then we will miss the
frame and produce a lot of Jenk.
The applications start-up,
there's a lot of Java code that
needs to be executed during the
application start-up.  If the
run time is slow, the start-up
will be slow.
Boot times, a lot of code
executes during boot.  Battery
time, if you are slow, we will
tank the battery.  And install
time is something that we care
about.  When we get an APK, the
platform will optimize it and
that could take a long time,
depending on how we implement
it.
And we don't want that long time
to happen, because we want you
to use the app right away.
And the other tool, which is
memory-relatememory-related, is
disk space.
It is how much space is the
runtime taking for its own opt
optimizations, and RAM.  Java
being Java, is there an
allocation that the runtime
needs to handle.  If it doesn't
do it well, it can take a lot of
RAM.
So this is essentially, there
has been three incarnations of
the Android runtime.
The first one was Dalvik, it was
the first implementation that
shipped with Android.
And Dalvik's purpose, or
Dalvik's main focus was how do
we save RAM? And the reason
being, back in the day, 10 years
ago, the RAM we had on the
phones we're shipping was even
less than 200MB.  And that was
very little if you want to
execute the whole Android stack.
So everything Dalvik was doing
was about, okay, how it  do we
save on RAM? So you cannot
generate any code, JIT or AOT is
how we generate code.  It
interprets the text code, what
is sent to Android for execution
over the app.  Eventually, you
get a Just in Time compiler so
you can generate native code.
But again, it was very limited
to what it could do, because RAM
was the main focus.
And, as you see, this was
tailored for apps not allocate
objects.  If you have been to
the talk this morning, things
have changed.  But, back in the
day, the recommendation was,
like, please avoid allocations.
And this worked well for, I
think, five years, until KitKat.
But there was, like, a point
where, like, Dalvik could not
keep up.  Phones were getting
bigger -- phones were getting
more performant, more RAM, like
the -- that was 2013 or 2014,
the 1GB, 2GB of RAM.
And apps were also getting
bigger.
So initially apps were supposed
to be like this small layer
between the UI and the
framework, but apps started
doing a lot of more and more
things.  So that 16 millisecond
window I talked for rendering a
frame, more was being executed
there.  So we have to do
something about it.  And the
answer happened in Lollipop with
ART,
which introduced ahead-of-time
compilation, and most of the
things were ahead-of-time
compiled, we were executing
native code for the app.  And
that is 20X faster than
interpretation.
And we also introduced, like, a
state-of-the-art GC, what you
find in regular runtimes of
being precise.  That means we
are not going to be confused by
an integer that looks like an
object.
But also generations, so that
the GC pauses we need to do in
the UI thread will be very
short.  So pauses will actually
end up creating Jenk.
The third incarnation is like an
evolution of art, it happened in
two releases, like Android
Nougat and Oreo.  In Nougat, we
introduced profile-guided
compilation.  I will explain a
bit later what it is.  But it
drastically helped on scaling
ARTART's ahead-of-time
technology to be more optimized
for the platform.
The profile guide compilation,
the way it works, it has a
hybrid, just-in-time,
out-of-time compiler.  We are
trying to use the best of both
worlds to optimize the platform.
And in O, after all of the
optimizations in N, in O, we
focused on the garbage collector
and implemented a band new one,
which makes the pause
even shorter on the UI thread.
We call it concurrent GC.  And
now all the GCC happens on a
different thread.  It is not
affecting the execution of the
app.
All right.  So before I dive
into our details, I want to show
this, the state of the Android
distribution today.
And, in case you are still
optimizing for Dalvik and you
still care about this annoying
GCFORALLOC, there is still this
10 percent, 10 percent is
KitKat, Jellybean, about 10
percent of devices are running
KitKat.  So my recommendation is
it matters, 10 percent is 20
million users, a big number.
So it still matters.  And give
it a couple years, and hopefully
in two years, that will be gone
and Dalvik can be part of
this museum.
All right.  So things ART
matters for.  I have put eight
boxes, they look nice, and we do
matter a lot for this.  If we do
get it wrong, things will go bad
on your device.
Role performance I talked about.
That's Dalvik's execution, Jenk,
application start-up, battery,
disk space, RAM, boot times, I'm
repeating myself.  This is what
is really important, what makes
the user experience okay so you
can enjoy the
apps.
So I'm going to go over the
releases I talked about, the
different incarnations of the
Android runtime to show what it
brings to the -- so what makes
ART today.  Because ART has a
lot -- like I said, it has a lot
of evolutions.  And we also took
good things from Dalvik.  I'm
missing the major ones here,
because the list is too long.
And obviously, the major thing
that Dalvik architecture brought
was RAM savings.
And, for that, Dalvik introduced
-- Dalvik on the Android
platform introduced the Zygote,
which is the parent process that
creates all of the other
processes.
And because it is the parent
process, you have the option of
that parent process starting up
or allocating a lot of memory
for the apps to use, and that
memory can be shared with the
other apps.
And that is super important,
that means that every app
doesn't need to allocate this
memory that it would need to
actually execute in ART.
Today, I surround a couple dozen
MB that we save per app, and
that the zygote allocates and
shares with the other apps.
And then Lollipop was the major
shift when we introduced
ahead-of-time compilation.
Ahead-of-time compilation
happens with an SSA compiler,
that's a compiler buzzword that
is -- a state of the art
compiler that does a lot of
optimizations and makes your
code up to 20X faster.
And we introduce the
ahead-of-time compiler that
helped a lot on reducing Jenk,
now the code was compiled, not
needing to be interpreted very
fast, reducing application
startup, the same argument, and
saving battery.  The execution
being 20X faster, you can
imagine that it is not a point
of saving 20X times on battery,
but things are faster and we
don't need to execute on the CPU
anymore.
We also save on boottimes.  The
whole Android OS is ahead of
time compiled and does not need
to be interpreted at boot.  So
things are faster at boot.
And we also introduced the
international GC, which reduced
the pauses for Alloc in Dalvik.
And
in Oreo, we introduced
profile-guided compilation, and
that helps with all of the
optimizations that we do.  It
helps a lot of these metrics.
It helps on Jenk, like less
code, less compiled, and the
things that we care about are
optimized so the UI thread needs
to run less code.  And it helps
on the application
application, we're able to know
what matters at start-up so
that, when we recompiled the
app, we recompiled it with
optimizations that optimize
start-up.  You will have some
battery.  Again, we're saving on
the amount of things we
interpreted.
It will have some div space.
Instead of compiling the entire
app, which is what Lollipop was
doing, now we are only compiling
the hard parts of the app.  That
means 10 to 20 percent of the
dex code.  So 80 percent just
doesn't get compiled.  That's a
lot of savings.
It saves on RAM, having a
concurrent GC means we can do a
lot of defrag of the heaps of
the app, so we save that on the
fragmentation that we had on the
previous GC.
And profile guided compilation
helps on the boot times.
Remember the optimizing aches
dialogue, we didn't need to AOT
compile at boot all of the apps
to make sure that the device was
reasonable and performant.  We
were able to just, okay, we take
the OTA, we are going to jit all
the apps, when the user wants
it, and then eventually we will
do profile-guided compilation of
the apps when the user is not
using their phone.
And then, finally, it helps on
install times.  Instead of
waiting for the compiler to
compile the entire app when you
install, now it doesn't compile
at all.  We rely on JIT the
first time the app was being
used.
And, lastly, I wanted to mention
Pie.  The time we developed Pie
was at the same time at Android
Go, which was a great effort in
the Android platform.  And we --
the work we did was mostly to
save on disk space and RAM,
because Android Go
is 5 or 12GB of the memory.  So
most of our efforts were focused
on improving RAM and disk space.
So in that release, we
introduced compact dex, which is
a compact version of the dex
format.  That saves on RAM,
because the less you need to put
into the memory of the dex code,
the more you are saving,
obviously.
Also, when the APK has
uncompressed text stored, we
will not uncompress it on disk.
So before, before we used to
uncompress it to do
optimizations on the dex file
you cannot do on the APK because
it is signed.  So before pi, we
uncompress it, do optimizations,
and rely on them on the first
few iterations before we do
profile-guided compilation.  Now
we get the option, give it to
the developer, if the developer
wants to save on disk space,
then put the dex file
uncompressed in DPK.  We are not
going to uncompress it on
device, we have one version of
the dex code and not a
compressed version of the APK
and an uncompressed one on disk.
All right.  That was a lot of
optimizations.  I wanted to
focus on one, which is raw
execution performance.  What you
saw this morning was pretty cool
with 18X, this is even cooler.
So obviously, the faster ART
runs, the more we are saving on
battery on application on
start-up and making the UI
smooth.  It matters, all of the
opt  optimizations we do.
And, over the releases, we have
kept improving the performance
by looking at actual
applications.  In this case, it
is the Google sheets.  And every
release we worked on, okay, how
do we improve the Google sheets
app.  And the Google sheets app,
or the sheets team, helped us to
build benchmarks how long it
takes to do
sheets manipulation.
Here, hire is better, blow  blue
is Dalvik, it is a score of one,
relative to Dalvik in terms of
performance.  Red is Lollipop,
where we introduced ART.  And
this is where we are today.  We
went into a 4X improvement when
we went to ART, to a 10X today
or a 26X on benchmark.  We are
happy with those numbers.  We
didn't look just at sheets, we
tried to look at what happened
to other apps.
So a couple years ago, we also
worked with the Chrome and
YouTube team to see what they
should optimize.  And there
again, after the fact, even
though we were not focused on
optimizing those benchmarks, we
saw that we had this 4 to 6X
improvement with what we've
done.
So there are two examples, the
JavaScript benchmark suite that
we imported for R purposes.  And
again, 2 to 4X, 3.5X for those
benchmarks, up to 6X in Pie.
And
ExoPlayer, that's the video
persister, driving the YouTube
app on Android.  And again,
around 2X for the introduction
of ART and 4X today in Pie.
And while I have your attention
on performance, I have a
shamless call to do.  We are
always super interested in
improving code you think is
important.
So if, on your side, you like us
to show off how we improved
performance of your app, please
come talk to us, there's the
office hours from 1:00 to 6:00
this afternoon, and we would be
really interested in knowing
what you think we should care
about performance.
And we can show that off
here.
All right.
So the question, then, is as we
get to this level of
improvements, how?
I mentioned that ART has a
modern compiler implementation,
SSA.  And thanks to the modern
SSA compilation, there's a bunch
of optimizations where we are
able to do now.
If you look at the compiler,
things can look
familiar, with the debt
coordination.  I will not go
overall  all of them.  I will
focus on an example that shows
how the optimizations matter,
especially on Kotlin that puts a
lot of abstractions to help on
the produck tubty of the user,
and makes it challenging for the
runtime to optimize.
All right.
So we will take the simple
method.  Very simple, it is a
function that takes one argument
and returns a length.
When we run
that to our dex serve, this is
the code that you get.  Pretty
straightforward, if you are not
familiar with dex code, you
create the string, and then
Kotlin having Nonnullable types,
it will make sure that the
string is not null when it is
passed to the function, so it
adds the helper method and
checking that the perimeter is
not null.
Then invoke field tool of the
length method on the argument
and return that.
Kotlin comes with the built-in
library, so that's where you can
find implementations of those
helper methods.  For that case,
it is only a simple method that,
okay, is the argument null? Yes.
Then I will throw, calling in
another helper, or R will return
and go back to the method.
So method calls are pretty
expensive.  So the first thing
that ART will do is try to
in-line that very small method
within the caller.
Here the compiler is in line
with the place that it is
called.  For simplicity's
reason, it looks like the text
code, it is the format of the
compiler, but I will not show
that to you.
Compile code is in line, which
helps with the performance.
There is more that we can do,
the compiler sees, oh, wait,
that throw
parameter is null and it always
-- throws.  There's a couple
things you can do with that
information.
The first is call layout, where
you can put together the regular
flow of the method.  So things
that rarely happen, you put it
at the very end of the method,
it does not affect the flow of
the execution.
So we just switched the
compilers in from, hey, are
these zero, and we jump to the
end of the
method.
So the jump is another picture
now.
The second optimization, we're
going to move things that the
regular flow does not care
about.  In this case, let me
just go back if I can.  In this
case, the construction of the
string that iss being passed to
the helper was the first thing
you executed in the method.  But
you only need that if you end up
calling the helper.  So-soo we
move the construction of the
string before the helper.
Meaning, we don't need to
execute examine.
So in the end, we started with a
method that was calling a
string, a helper, doing it's
thing, returning the length, to
a method that is checking if it
is null, if it is, jump to an
expressive jump somewhere.  If
it is not, we will continue the
flow and return the length of
the method, the length of the
string, sorry.
All right.
So that was raw performance.  I
have two other things to talk
about, actually, just one,
because I have to talk about
application start-up and garbage
collection.  I will not re-do
the garbage collection side,
Chet did a great job this
morning.
So, with application start-up,
it has been a major focus since
we introduced
profile-guided compilation.
That happened in nougat.
Profile-guided compilation, when
the app is installed, we compile
it in a quick way.  We are not
going to go to full IOT
compilation, very little
optimizations that do not affect
install time.  So we are
optimizing install time.  The
app is installed, then you run
it.  The app is being executed,
with interpretation, and then
method gets hot, and then JIT
kicks in and compiles the
methods.
The JIT knows what those hot
methods are, so we are going to
jump to a profile file to sub
methods. So when your device is
idle, the user is not using it,
it is charging, 100 percent
charged, and then we have this,
what we call, profile-guided
demon that is just like, okay,
then you walk over all the
profiles and recompile the app.
And compile them, compile only
the things that matter based on
that profile.
And you have this loop where the
next time you run the app, we
will use the optimized version
of the compile code.  And then
we will run it what is IOTed,
maybe some methods are missed,
you reinterpret them, re-update
the profile, and the demon kicks
in, the profile was updated, let
me recompile the app.
So it is a virtuous loop of
getting better and better over
time.
And why is that helping on the
application
start-up?
The things that we compile in
the app in the profile are
optimized towards this.  We are
going to compile the start-up
methods.  So no need to
interpret them, things that are
executed at start-up will get
compiled.
We're going to layout the dex
and the compile code.  So things
that execute at start-up would
be next to each other.
So now you don't need to jump
over the entire dex file to get
access to the method.  And that
is very important.  Like I said,
apps got bigger.  So if you need
to bring up the entire dex file,
for start-up, that is a lot of
time waiting on I/O.  So we try
to reduce that by putting
everything in start-up in the
beginning and then the rest at
the end.
Profile-guided compilation
generates an application image.
Other runtimes will call this a
snap shot.  It is a
representation of Java classes
that we put in that image, it is
a file, and that avoids us to
actually load the classes at run
time again.  So there's a
pre-formatted number of classes
with a class order, and when we
start-up, you take the class
order, all of the classes are
populated, and we are done.  You
don't need to do code
clustering anymore.
We are going to try to
preinitialize classes, so Java
says classes need to be
initialized before executed.
With profile guided compilation,
we need to initialize anything
we can to prevent that from
being executed before we start
the app.  And finally, I said
we're not going to compile code
that doesn't get executed.  That
helps a lot.  Because then your
old file is very small, your
compile file is very small.  So
there's not a lot you need to
bring up in memory to actually
compute.
What do we gain from all those
optimizationoptimizations?
Well, they can be -- we always
gain doing those optimizations.
Depending on the app, it can be
10 percent or 30 percent.
And that is usually around how
many Java code do you have when
you start your app.  Typically,
camera has a lot of native code,
that is on the low end of 10
percent improvement.
And in this example, you see
docs and maps, that are very
Java-heavy, go from 30 percent
of app start-up
improvement.
And this is numbers that we got
from the maps team, who got that
from actual users, or actual
data that comes from the field.
And when the maps team graphs
what is going on, how come --
had they installed, things were,
like, a one second of apps
start-up to, over time, things
are faster.  How does that
happen? And every time they
update the app, it is the same
trend.  It starts pretty high,
and then it goes low.
And the answer is profile guided
compilation.  You are clearly
seeing that, over time, things
get better.
Today, in Pie, when we talked
about I/O last year was the
introduction of profiles in the
cloud.  And that's how we're
making the entire ecosystem send
us profiles, like actually
execution of profiles for users,
so we can bring the profiles to
new users of the app, so you
don't get a -- the start of one
second ends up 750 milliseconds,
they get the 750 right away,
because they get the profile at
the point of
the of
install. .
Garbage collection, I'm not
going over it.
Maybe I can just put back a
number that we're all
very proud of, here we are,
that's the last.  So this is
resuming what Chet talked about
this morning.  It is all the
technology that we've used over
time for building a GC.  So you
see in KitKat,
we have this concurrent mark
suite that was part of the GC
that was concurrent.  And it
stayed until Nougat, in Oreo,
the concurrent collector.  The
allocation in KitKat, it was the
bottleneck, it needs to lock to
allocate something.  The
introduction of a new GC in
Lollipop meant that we can
allocate within the thread and
not need the lock.
That improves the performance of
allocation.
The -- when you allocate the
objects that are short lived,
and that's the motoof Java Java,
feel free to allocate Java, it
is moved by the GC in Java.
Pre-KitKat, that is not the
case, you have a very high cost
by allocating temporary objects.
Lollipop is when we introduced a
new GC, and the -- you didn't
pay that cost at all.  Like
allocating a short-lived object,
we had generations, things were
moved pretty quickly.  And
there's an app series for Oreo,
when we introduced concurrent
collector, we removed the
generations out of the
collector.  We are fixing that
today, it is in the AOSP, the
improvement of the generations.
And hopefully it will be there
in the device
soon.
And fragmentation, fragmentation
is a big problem in Android,
because if you are not able to
allocate, the app will be
killed.  So doing compassion of
the memory, so that things are
not fragmented is super
important.  KitKat did a bit,
but very little, and Lollipop in
marshmallow , we did it when the
app was running in the
background.  We reclaim the
memory.  But Oreo, it is
important that we compact all
the time so the memory is there
and available all the time.
And the number I was looking
for, the allocation speed, a
very low number in Dalvik, to an
18X improvement in Oreo and
Pie.
And here are the reasons -- the
reasons that we got improved,
Lollipop added a custom
allocator, and in Marshmallow,
we had erfeweratomic operations
that have a cost.  And all of
that implementation of the
allocation path was moved to an
assembly code in nougat that
made things faster, and then we
implemented the pointer in
allocation.  And the only thing
we allocate is to increment a
pointer.
All right.  With that, this is
the recommendation that Chet
has.
So I will give the same.
Creating garbage is
okay today.
You can use a tag to allocate
the objects that you need.
GC is still overhead, so be
mindful that if you allocate
allocate a lot of objects, GC
needs to run, but it is less of
a problem since Dalvik.
And, with that, thank you.
[ Applause ].
SPEAKER: I will be in the office
hours at 1:00PM.  Feel free to
come and chat there.
.
SPEAKER: Everyone, please give a
warm welcome to dan Galpin.
SPEAKER: We have lunch going on
right now, we are on a different
schedule today.  So once again,
lunch is where it was yesterday,
downstairs.  And we're going to
start our sessions at 1:05.  We
are trying to smash as much
--.
#
Coming up next: Android Emulator
Deep Dive by Frank Yang, Yahan
Zhou SPEAKER: Good afternoon,
welcome to the Android deep
dive.  I'm Yahan, this is
fraFrank and we are software
engineers from the Android team.
Back in 2015 in the previous
Android dev summit, we announced
Android Emulator.
So if you remember here is what
it looks like in 2015.  And it
is 2018 now, so things have
progressed quite quickly, and we
have a new Emulator with a newer
look.
So if you look at the details,
there's a few differences that
you might have
noticed.
First, there's a frameless skin
, and it gives you a better UI
experience.
And secondly, you might have
noticed that, in the expanded
panel, there is a much longer
feature list, with new features
such as screen
recording and support, snap
shot, and Google Play Store.  I
will go over all these features
in this talk one by one.
From 2015 to 2018, we have
developed quite a lot of stuff
in the Android Emulator, and we
are focused on two areas.
One is the performance
improvement of the Emulator, the
other is the new features.
And we are focusing on the
improvng your day-to-day
developing experience as far as
CI server testing use
cases.
So, first things first, let's
get into performance.  The first
thing we want to focus on about
performance is HyperVisor
support.  So just a background
about Hypervisors, if you are
running the Android Emulator at
the lowest level, you have your
computer hardware.
On top of that, you have your
operating system, and the
highest level, there
is the Android OS.  Between the
OS and the operating system,
there's the hardware which
translates the Android CPU
commands into your OS series of
commands.
That's the a part that we do the
CPU acceleration.  If you don't
have a
HyperVisor, you can run the
emulator, but everything is
super slow and the emulator
becomes super sluggish.
So, in 2015, here is the list of
the hardware that we support.
On Linux, we have KVM, and on
Windows and Mac, we support HAXM
with Intel CPU.  So
unfortunately, back in the days,
if you are using a CPU on a
Windows machine, we have no
support for this combination.
So we got a lot of request from
A&D users, to add support for
them.  So it is 2018 now, things
progress pretty fast, and
obviously, we have new
HyperVisors approach.  So this
supports a new version of HAXM,
7.3.2, which is the previous
version and it gives you better
performance.
And then we added
HyperVisor.framework support for
Mac users which, in most
situations, is faster than the
HAXM on Mac.
And, at last, we support
hypervisor framework,
known as HyperV on Windows.  So
the combination of NDN and
Windows is supportive,  .  So
here is the HyperVisor
performance.
And the next thing we want to go
into
will be the ADP performance.  So
the Oreo background, you move
from the computer, on to the
device when you are deploying,
you are doing this ADB push
command which copies and
transfers the app from one end
to the other.
So here, we are showing the
chart for ADB push time on a
physical device on two different
Google apps: The Google photo
app, and Google center checker
app.  And they are both on
physical devices.  And you can
see what the first thing was,
that if you are using a USB
cable and you are pushing the
Google photo app, it takes
approximately eight
seconds.
If you are using a USB cable,
it goes a lot faster, and it
takes approximately four
seconds.  So you can observe
similar momentum when pushing a
similar app, like the Google
check
up.
USBKs are faster than USBK2s.
So that's for the physical
device.  How about the
performance on the Emulator?
So here's a chart.  If you do
the app push on Emulator, the
Google photo apps take
approximately 0.5 seconds, which
is a lot faster than USB2 or
USB3.
And this other chart on an
Android Oreo device. And it
turns out that the OS version
matters a lot as well when we
are doing the app push.
So we've got a chart on the
nearer Android Pie device.  If
you are working on a physical
device, the ADP push is a lot
faster on either USB2 or 3.
And Emulator still gives you a
very fast and a very constant
performance.
So, in short, if you are going
to the emulator, you are not
going have any worries about USB
cables or
Android versions.  You can
always get the best and
consistent performance.
The next topic, we are going to
Quick Boot and snap Shots.  We
are showing demoes.  And with
that, we will have
Frank.
SPEAKER: Thank you, Yahan.  A
top concern of Android Studio
users is time to deploy the app,
whether it be on a physical
device or emulator.  And people
are used to the workflow where
they are inside studio, want to
deploy the app, and they want to
wait for the Emulator to boot up
again.  We tried to address this
in 2017 and in 2018.
The first way we tried to
address this is through snap
shots.
We call this quick boot.
With quick boot, the device
state is completely saved when
you take a snap shot.  And when
you take a snap shot when you
exit the emulator and you resume
from that snap shot when you
start the emulator again.
So, in a sense, it is kind of
like sleeping and resuming a
real device.  And we've also
made improvements in recent
emulator Canary versions to make
it even closer to that.  So the
demo I'm going to show you here
is I have two ABDs set up in the
ABD manager.  One of them is
called API 28, and we're going
to be using quick boot with
that.  And a second one is
called API28 cold boot, and
we're going to cold boot that.
So for our benefit, people
haven't seen this already.  I'm
going to cold boot one of these
ABDs.  You will see that it
starts out as a black screen,
takes a while to show the Google
logo but, with quick boot, the
Emulator pops up right here.
You will notice that the log cat
started up, and we can interact
with it immediately, just as the
Cold Boot emulator has just
started up.
So we are going to get rid of
the Cold Boot emulator for now
and move to the next part of the
demo.  In addition to Quick Boot
in July of 2018, we extended the
snap shots feature to be more
general.  So with quick boot,
you can only have one snap shot
being saved and loaded at any
one tile.  Time.  That is
usefulx , but maybe you want to
test different device
configurations and state and so
forth.  Before now, we didn't
have a good way to do that.  In
the latest Emulator stable
version, 27.3.10, released July
2018, we are giving you a
generic snap shots UI.  In this
generic snap shots UI, you can
save and load snap shots
arbitrarily.  So for example, I
can immediately
resume one of these snap shots
to stop watch running, and a
stop watch is running.  I can
edit any one of these snap shos
and add notes.
And the description is saved and
also displayed over here.
I can also take new snap shots
with the take snap shot button.
So these are some examples of
what we have been doing with
snap shots in trying to make
your life easier when you are
deloying apps and testing them.
I would also like, at this
point, go over some improvements
we made to the quick boot
mechanism itself in recent
emulator canaries.  The version
of the Emulator running right
now is 28.0.15.  And the recent
Emulator car nary, we tried to
listen to your concern about
extremely long saving time for
the Emulator when you are
closing it.  Now if you want to
save the Emulator, actually,
wait, we will set up the stop
watch again.  It is saved, trust
me, it is.
Yes, it was saved.
So we have employed new
technologies, like file backing
of the guest RAM in order to
speed this process up.
And in addition, we have also
added some console commands that
are useful for CI users when
using snap shots.
One very common workflow is to
reset the device to a particular
previous state, and then run
your test in  and reset the
device again.  To that end, we
added this command called, in
the console, it is called ABD
snap shot remap 0.
So assuming that you are using a
default setting, it is like you
are auto saving the current
device state all the time.  So
right now, we are on the second
-- we are up 40 seconds.
So the 1st time you run this, it
will save it around then.  The
next time you run it, it will
quickly rewind there.  So this
happens quite quickly because
all the rest of the Emulator UI
and all of that is set up, it is
just a device state that is
changing.
So you can just keep doing this,
like rewinding very quickly, you
can be unany state of the device
and just keep going back to that
one state very quickly with this
command.
And another feature that we have
been working on in recent
Emulator canaries is launching
multiple instances of the same
ABD.
So let me just set this up
again.
Okay, zero seck  seconds.
So before, when you are using
the Emulator.  If you want to
test multiple different device
dates and launch them all at the
same time in parallel, your
options are pretty limited.  You
have to create a bunch of ABDs
that reflect the different
device settings and launch them
all in parallel, or you could
start two instances of the same
ABD -- couldn't -- because you
got the same message that the
ABD is in use.  We have a
command for that now, read only.
Where  I will show you the
command here.
Okay.
Actually, it is missing, but I
will type it again.
So it is called dash read dash
only.  So when you run this
command, the emulator will
start, but the start all
changes.  I am starting it in
the background to make it easy
to start many of them.
So I have just started a second
one, it is actually overlapped
on the first.  A third one u , a
fourth one.  So you have these
ABDs that are running
independently, but off the same
ABD name, because I used API 28
for each of them.  And I'm
cleaning up the FPS and memory
stats.  Why are some of these
only 200 or 300MB of resident
memory? That goes back to using
a file mapping for the guest
RAM.  In this case, the parts of
the guest memory that they share
in common that they have not
modified yet will be shared and
will not occupy proportional
size or resident memory or
what-have-you.
So this is called copy on write.
And we hope that this makes your
experience developing apps and
testing them more streamlined.
Thank you.
Now back to Yahan, back to the
slides.
YAHAN ZHOU: I think it is
obvious to see the comparison if
you are using the quick boot
feature versus if you are doing
the cold boot.
So, in the cold boot, if it
takes you more than 20 seconds
to do the save on your machine
as you are demoing today, and on
Quick Boot, it is usually about
one second.
So back to Frank for the next
demo.
SPEAKER: Uh-huh, back to the
So the next part starts out with
we also improved the GPU
performance of the emulator in
recent versions and in recent
years.  We worked a lot to bring
open GL ES2 support very
conformant and to support open
EL GS3.
So this end, we created some
benchmark demo apps that
showcase what the emulator is
capable of.
So I am starting this test over
here.
And so you can run the realtime
3D applications like this that
are competitive with real device
performance.
But, before we go any further, I
would like to go back to Yahan
in the slides to go over another
interesting feature.
SPEAKER: All right.  So, coming
back to the Snapshot support.
If you remember in 2010, the
emulator, before 2.0, we had the
quick boot feature and snap shot
tutorial.  At the time, the
emulator supports snap shots for
RAM, Disk, and CPU.  The missing
part here was GPU-based snap
shots.
So this eventually led us to
choose between hardware GPU
emulation and the quick boot
feature.
If you choose the hardware GPU
emulation, you getty pretty nice
runtime performance.  But your
boot time is a slow boot.  If
you choose the quick boot
feature, your boot time will be
fast, but you will have no run
time hardware GPU support, which
means the runtime performance
will suffer.
So this is in 2010, and people
have had to choose between the
two.  And it is 2018 now, and we
have better versions of
everything, including the
hardware GPU snap shot support.
This allows our users to choose
both the quick boot feature as
well as hardware GPU emulation
simultaneously.
So if you look at what was
happening behind the scenes for
this hardware GPU snap shot
support, here is the emulator
GPU stack.  At the highest
level, you have the Android OS,
which issues GPU commands.
At the lowest level, you have
your hardware graphics card,
which sets the commands.  And we
have the emulator, called the
translator.  And the translator
will translate the GPU commands
from Android into your hardware
GPU.
And when we are doing the GPU
snapshot support, we put all of
the logic into the translator
layer so that if you serialize
this own state and dump them
into your snap shot saved file.
So one big question here was the
hardware states, which is
eventually over to the emulator
and different renderrors render
differently.
So to use the hardware state, we
standard the APIs to fetch the
hardware space from the hardware
to the translator layer, and
then we serialize all of them
and wrap it into the snap shot
file.  In this case  in this
case, we can save and recover
the whole emulated hardware GPU
state.
So --
SPEAKER: All right, thank you
Yahan.  In this demo, I will
demonstrate that the GPU state
is snap shotted in its entirely.
We did not do something special,
it can resume 3D apps like this
almost immediately with the
snapshot load feature.
All right.
And you can, for those of you
who don't know already, you can
rotate the emulator in rotation,
using the rotation buttons.
Back to the slides I would like
show a brief presentation.
All right.  So I know that many
of you know this already, but
for the benefit of people thin
audience who don't know yet, I
would like to recap on some of
the basic ways to use the
command line to launch the
emulator, which can include
useful options if you are
running a CI server, or power
user.
So the emulator and the
Android SDK folder, Android
SDK/emulator.  And in the
directory, you have to give the
ABD command line option, may be
different than what is displayed
in the ABD manager.  If you want
to know the exact sequence of
characters to input there, then
you run
emulator-listABDs.
Second, how it  do you control
quick boot.  Sometimes you don't
want to use snap shots or save
your changes
on exit.
So the first snap shot is to
attempt to load the current
state on the device, cold boot.
The second, quick boot, it
dischards changes to the snap
shot for CI use cases and if you
want the consistent start up
experience and want to wipe it
clean when they are done with
it.  In this, you enter no snap
shot save on the command line.
And all of the changes to the
snap shot will be discarded when
you exit the emulator.  Finally,
if snap shots are not your
thing, you can add no snap shot
to your command line.  That will
bring the Emulator back to the
way it was before.
And to recap, in the demo I gave
earlier, in launching multiple
instances of the ABD, that's the
read only option.
That option will control whether
you are allowed to run multiple
instances of the same ABD or
not.  When you are running in
that mode, all of the changes to
both the guest virtual disk and
to the snap shot, whatever you
do, it is discarded when you
exit.
So invoke this, you would run
emulator-ABD, the AB it  D name,
followed by read-only.  I put in
an ampersand, you don't have to,
but convenient for demo purposes
here.
All right.  Now, I want to talk
about some of the command line
options super some of the
features that we have introduced
recently to the emulator.
In particular, screen record.
Screen record is a feature where
you can record the contents of
the emulator to a video file,
and then play them back using
your favorite app.
This is great for CI users who
want to be able to easily record
what is going on when running
tests on their app, and to
easily send reproductions of
bugs to stakeholders.
So the first set of commands
concerns how to start and stop
the screen recording.
ADBADBemu screenrecord start,
followed by the path to the
file, will start the recording.
And it is important that you
provide the absolute path.
Otherwise, you might not get it
saved.  It is a little
confusing.  Sorry, working on
it.
The second command, ABDemu
screen record stop, it stops
recording and there's a menu to
save the file.  So after you to
it do do that, you can access
the file. And the third one
concerns if you don't want the
whole video recording part, you
can just instead take a
screenshot.  In this use case,
the console command is screen
record screenshot, followed by a
path to the directory where you
want the screenshots to be
saved.
Now, let's go to the demo where
I will demonstrate the screen
recording commands.
So we are in Emulator right now,
and let's try to find a
different app to record, we will
start up the camera.  So while
that is going on, I'm going to
run this, so ADB emu, screen
record, start, users, user name,
documents, they have summit,
demo.webm.
So while it is recording, we
will just move around in here a
little bit to make something
happen.
And we will stop the
recording.
And that is kind of it  -- I
accidentally typed ADB there.
So we will do another
recording.
All right.  So the video is
saved, and you can open it in
your favorite web
browser.
Okay.
Let's see, there we go.
So it is a Web M file, it will
work in most major browsers.
Second, there's always an UI for
recording these screens.
It is in the extended controls
under the screen record tab.  So
in the screen record tab, it
starts with a single button,
start recording.  So once we are
starting recording, we will move
around a little bit, go to
recent, swipe away, and stop.
And now once you are done
recording, you don't have to
save it to a file.  You can
preview it directly in the
extended controls UI.
So it is just a video of what we
just did.
Go to recent, swipe away the
apps, go back to the home
screen.  But you can still save
it wherever you want.
So let's just save this as demo
two.  And that, similarly, works
in the browser.
Okay, so that's one of the
features that we've added in
2017 and 2018 is screen
recording to make your CI use
cases better.
Another feature that we've been
doing a lot of work on and it is
pretty exciting is AR core
support.  Now, AR core support
consists of a few mage
components: The first one, as
you may have seen already, is
the virtual scene camera.  With
the virtual scene camera, we
render a virtual environment,
which is suitable to image
recognition and model placement
in AR apps.
So I will demonstrate a few of
them here.  In the back ground,
in Android Studio, I have opened
the augmented image, AR score
sample.  This is available in
scene form Android S it  DK from
GitHub.  And what AR core
provides, and it is not just for
the emulator, but integrations
in studio as well.  So, for
example, there's this scene form
plugin for Android Studio where
we can view models that are
meant for recent error core
apps.  In addition, we can
change all the material
properties we want in studio.
So this is the lower left frame,
and I might just say, lower the
red tint
a bit.
I guess that did not change the
color very much, so I will
change blue to zero as well.
So once you save these files,
the model should get reloaded.
And you will see that it is
mostly green now.  And the
workflow, we can edit the model
and deploy it to the device
while we wait,
I guess.
All right.  So, in this app, we
are looking for images to
recognize.  Another feature that
we have added to the emulator
for AR core support is the
ability to load augmented
images, this is in the extended
controls panel under the camera
tab.  We can choose different
posters to appear inside the
virtual scene, and I have set
this JPEG of the earth to appear
on the table and the wall.  So
once you travel inside the scene
with this, and turn, face the
wall, we are starting to detect
the image and it shows up there.
So this show physical s if you
are a developer of AR apps, you
have an end to end workflow and
you can do it with scene camera.
So that's pretty cool.  Finally,
another feature I would like to
mention that I will call out,
unless you haven't seen it
before, is improved support for
updating GMS core in Google Play
services.  It is important to
app developers because you have
to test how the app will run
with different versions of core.
If you see the image in the
controls panel, there's a tab,
Google Play, and inside it,
there's a button that shows the
current GMS core version and a
button to up late it.  Once you
press update, you will be take n
tothe Play Store and be given
the option to update it.  I hap
happen to have it updated
already, it is the latest
version.  If a new version does
come out, it would say update.
I would also like to talk about
the integration of the Play
Store and the Emulator in
general.
So this can be useful for app
developers who would like to
test their app in more
end-to-end scenarios.  If your
app requires other apps to be
installed in order for it to
work, you can download them from
the Play Store directly.  Also,
you can look at your app in the
marketplace and see how users
are reacting to it right there
and from different device sizes
in different form factors.  And
so that concludes the feature
demoes.  So back to Yahan in the
slides.
SPEAKER: All right.
So here is the summary of the
features we talked about today.
You might have noticed that
there are two channels of the
emulator out there.  The first
is the stable channel that you
normally get.  The latest update
is from July 2018.  The second
channel is the canary channel,
which is less stable, but has
all of the cutting-edge features
we have in the emulator, and it
is released weekly.  Feel free
to try it out.  In the stable
channel, we have this feature,
this is already released,
including HyperVisor support,
quick boot feature, generic snap
shot SFEECHer, the Play Store,
the screen recording, and the AR
core and the virtual sensor
support.  If you are trying out
the canary channel emulator, you
have a few more steps, including
the faster quick boot feature,
as we have shown in today's
demo, as well as the
multiinstance support.
And for those of you who are
curious on how to switch the
channel, you can create the
instruction.  In the Android
Studio, you can turn on your
preference page.  In the update,
you have your channel switch
right there.
And after that, you go to the
emulator download page and use
the newer version available for
download.
So I believe that concludes our
talk.
So we will be QAing in the
laundry, so thanks for attend
attending.  Thank you.
[ Applause ] 1QU #
St.
Coming up next: Vitals: Past,
Present & Future by Fergus
Hurley, Riccardo Govoni.
C  SPEAKER: Hey, everyone.
Thank you very much for joining
today.
I'm Fergus Hurley and I'm
excited to talk to you about the
past, present, and future of
Android V  vitlsals, Google's
initiative to improve the
stability and performance of
devices.  We are doing a lot to
help this, in the play console,
we have section, Android Vitals.
That's where we report to you
different performance metrics we
are going to cover in this
talk.
How we empower this is
interesting, hundreds of
thousands of users share their
diagnostics data, and we share
that data in a privacy-compliant
way within the product.  I will
start by going through lessons
we learned over the last 18
months as we launched vitals
from top developers out there
that are big and small that have
actually used Android Vitals and
gotten a lot of success from
using them.
So hands up here if you want
less one-star ratings? If you
don't have your hand up, you
might be in the wrong
conference, unfortunately.
But most people want to avoid
them.  What we found when we
looked at the review corpus on
Google play, which is pretty
large, is that 40 percent of all
one-star reviews were extracted
and talking about stability in
bugs.  Over the past year, the
percentage of users talking
about stability has gone down 18
percent.  We are going to talk
about the developers that
contributed to this
reduction.
The emerge dragons team has used
Android Vitals to pin point
where there is an issue with
their application and this
resulted in them reducng their
one-star reviews by 50 percent.
The very popular Reddit app used
Android Vitals to be able to
reduce their crash rate by 75
percent.  They did this because
they were able to see the
category benchmarks in the play
console Android Vitals section.
And they were able to make the
case with their leadership that
they had room for improvement,
and then when they actually
improved their metric, they were
able to show leadership, hey, we
have actually done what we set
up to do and we are one of the
most stable apps out there.
The logo team signed up for the
anomaly emails, and they got
notified when there was an issue
in their application.  They had
a huge spike caused by an SDK
they were using in their
application.  And even though
you might be building an amazing
product yourself and think it is
stable, I'm sure you have used
third party libraries and some
of them can introduce issues in
your application.  You want to
become aware of that as soon as
possible.  And anomaly alerts
distable it, and then they
shifted it to a new fix that
reduced their ANR rate down to
0.25
percent.
The AVA English team, pretty
small and they don't have
infinite resources to spend on
performance.  We don't think you
should spend all of your time
focusing on performance, either.
But you have to keep an eye on
performance all the time and it
might make sense for you to just
focus on improving the
performance of the application
and hold off on the new
features, maybe as part of
the '19Q1 planning.  This team
did that and reduced their ANR
rate by 97 percent as a result.
This, and a bunch of other
things, resulted in them being
able to increase their star
rating to 4.6 stars.  You cannot
get a 4.6 star reading if you
just focus on vitals, but you
will never get a terrible one if
you focus on vitals.
We looked at individual app
users using vitals.  We also
looked at, of the top thousand
apps on play, we looked at their
engagement in the vitals
section.  And the developers who
engaged most in the vitals
section, the top 10 percent,
they reduced their crash rate by
50 percent over that time
period.  And this isn't just
good for those developers and
those apps, they are good for
Android end users that resulted
in $3 billion more stable
installs on the
platform.
So we talked about stability,
and another major area that we
just talked about when they
leave one star reviews is
resource usage issues.  And this
is
battery, network, memory, etc.
We have a lot
interrelated.  One is excessive
network usage in the background
background.  It is consuming the
data plan and wasting the
battery.  We have two metrics to
help in this area, wake ups and
wake locks.  And the team
focused on their wake ups rate,
and they said they wouldn't have
even noticed or fixed their
excessive wake ups issues
without using Android Vitals, we
have a lot of insights in your
battery usage that few other
tools can help you with, and
they reduced their wake up rate
by 70 percent.
Now we're going to jump over to
how you can actually increase
your 5-star reviews.  And what
we find is over the past year,
we've had more users mentioning
speed, design, and usability,
which is what 70 percent of the
five-star reviews talk about
when we are able to find topics
in
them.
The mercado Libre team, number
one for eCommerce in Latin
America, they built a new
feature in the application,
requiring them to ask for a
certain permission, resulting in
a bad user experience where
users had a high denial rate of
this permission.  They would see
it in Android Vitals and
redesigned that feature to give
users an explanation of why they
needed it, that permission, and
only ask when the users actually
needed that for that specific
feature and not early on in the
process.
And Mercado Libre team is pretty
big. And what they found useful
is the ability to keep track on
many of the metrics and to see
that -- the start-up time,
there's was a regression in
reduces and that caused the
start-up time of the application
long.  They found out the team
that caused the issue and worked
to debug that
issue.
This team used the monitoric ing
tool to get deep am  insights.
And it does not cover in the
application where the issues
might occur, so that's why we
encourage you to use Firebase
performance monitoring as well
to understand where the specific
issues are occurring.  They
figured out that the log in and
sign up flow is taking too long
and they decided to re-write
that part of the application.
So what's in vitals today?
So vitals consists of five
performance areas that you will
agree are things you don't like
have happen when using apps, you
don't want it to crash, drain
your battery, slow in rendering,
requesting permissions you don't
need, and slow to start.
And so we have 15 metrics
covering these
these five performance areas
today.  And we showed you an OS
version, your APK breakdown,
device breakdown and, where
relevant, we provide other
information as well when it is
possible.
And a new feature that we
launched at I/O this year is
category benchmarks where you
can see, compared to other apps
in your category, where you
stack up compared to your peers
across every metric.  We give
you the 25th, 75th, and 50th
percentile break down for the
category benchmarks and that
helps you to understand, this
metric I'm doing okay on, and
this one I'm actually falling
way behind and need to invest
there.
I mentioned the anomaly alert
emails earlier.
These are available in the
console today, you have to opt
in to receive them.  So I
encourage you, if you are not
opted in already, to sign up
today and I encourage the rest
of your team to sign up as well.
And this is where we notify you
when there's a significant
change in the ANR crash rate of
your application, where you have
a spike in the clusters, or
across the core vitals that
we're going to talk about right
now.
There are 15 Android vital
metrics, it is a lot of metrics.
We think all of them are
important to deliver the best
possible user experience, but
some of them are more important
than others.  As talked about
earlier, the leading
contribution to one star
reviews are civility and baltry
issues.
THROOPS are four vitals across
those, crash and ANR
rate, and stuck partial wake
locks and excessive wakeups in
the battery area.  For each core
or vital, we give you a bad
behavior threshold.  If you are
above that threshold, you are
sort of failing the class.  That
bad behavior threshold is
looking at how it maps, the
bottom 25 percent of apps are
above this rate, and that's
where the bad
behavior is.
We launched the pre-launch
report a couple years ago, this
is when you upload your APK, we
would generate a report within
an hour of how your application
performs across those different
10 Android devices that you have
in the test lab when a robot is
navigating your application for
10 minutes.  It gives you a
report showing a screenshot
clustering and a bunch of
insights into accessibility
issues and privacy issues and
also flags crashes.
One we recently did is we
enabled you, when you look at a
crash cluster in the vitels
section is to see if we have a
pre-launch crash report that we
detected that matches the
pre-launch crash report.  And
there are not the same privacy
restrictions in place as there
are with the data from the
field, of course.
And so here, we can be able to
show you the video of the robot
interacting with your
application so you can quickly
reproduce that issue yourself
and we provide a lot more log
and detailed information.
We also did the reverse.  So we
have the ability to be able to
see when you are looking at a
pre-launch report, is this a
crash that is already happening
in the field, or is this one
that was introduced with my
latest APK and has not reached
users yet?
SPEAKER: We have over 100
developers using Android Vitals
today.  Hands up here, who is
using Android Vitals? Cool,
great.  Thank you guys for using
it.
And one of the things that I
found most interesting about
this project is that we have
expanded the number of users who
are using performance metrics,
or what we call engineering
metrics.
So I was previously working on
apps with another team at
Google, and we did that external
to Google before. And one of the
thing tat I struggled with is
understanding how these metrics
are doing.  We had to have the
latest version of the code, and
to be able to run the profilers
and we made it so it is really
easy for all the people in your
company to get access to these
performance metrics and be able
to see how you are doing
relative to the other people and
make a case for investing here,
versus the other features.  I
have shown some case studies
from different titles here, as
you would expect, you have an
Android engineer, a head of
mobile engineering and a product
manager using it.  And now we
have lead performance managers
using metrics, you have a CTO
and COOs using engineering
metrics.  I encourage you and
your teams to use these with
your senior leadership and with
the wider team.  And if you
don't, you are probably going to
get left behind.  Because
quality across the whole Android
ecosystem is improving.
So you would say, that is great,
it is impacting the other
developers, not me, my app is
awesome, even if it has a high
crash rate.  I don't believe
you.  We looked at the data of
users with a high crash rate
versus a lower or medium crash
rate.  If they have a higher
crash rate for the same app
leave 52 percent more reviews
than a low or medium one.
So I encourage you to use it if
you are not.
So what is the future of Android
Vitals?
Well, we have built a lot of
features, as you can tell so
far.
And so really the feature of
Android Vitals is you guys are
using the product.
And so, what we're going to do
is right it now, we're going to
try something different.  I want
everyone to stand up, and talk
to the people beside you, so try
to find -- there you go.  Yep.
And find someone beside you who
hopefully you have not worked
with and just introduce yourself
and we're going to take two
minutes for one person to talk
about their vitals and how they
are approaching it, and who in
their company uses it, what are
the best practices involved, and
then switch the role for two
minutes.  I will give you two
minutes now, and then we will
switch over.
SPEAKER: If you haven't had the
other person talk, switch over
and we will have one
more minute.
SPEAKER: Thank you very
much, everyone.
I hope you learned something
from the people you talked to,
and made a new friend as well.
So I would encourage you to talk
to other people about how they
are approaching their vitals.
There's lot of documentation
online to help you as well, and
we will be at the booth outside
afterwards on the right hand
side when you walk out of this
room if you have any questions
as well.  One of the things that
you probably realize talking to
the person is that one of the
biggest problems with vitals
today is actionability, we heard
you and your feedback, and we
appreciate that.  And I want to
show you that is something we
are working hard to improve and
we have more to come on that in
the future.  We do believe that
the data is valid in terms of
telling you the direction to go
as in, like, you are doing good
or bad versus other people.  And
we think we can do better in
terms of helping you be more
efficient at fixing the problem.
But that is a really hard
problem, and we are working on
changes to the whole OS it elf
itself.
Those things take a while to
propagate across the Android
user base and to be able to have
enough data to share back with
you within the console is
something we are working on.  I
want to thank you all very much
for joining us today, and best
of luck with improving your
vitals.  I hope I get to share
your vitals' success stories in
our talk next year.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]
.
Coming up next: Re-stitching
Plaid with Kotlin by Florina
Muntenescu.
SPEAKER: Hello,
everyone.
I'm Florina Muntenescu, a
developer advocate at Google.
For the past few months, me are
working on bringing Plaid in
fashion, it was brought by a
colleague of a way of showcasing
material design.  We are seeing
the state of the
app in 2016 in Plaid glory days.
We see animations and
VectorDrawables and a lot of
these made the app shine and
improved the user experience.
So Plaid takes data from three
different sources.
And, well, these sources from
2016 until now, well, some of
them were deprecated.
So that meant that, out of three
sources, we were left with one
and a little bit.
So, from all of these nice,
fancy UI features that we had,
we were left with almost nothing
and with a pretty boring
application.
So we decided we didn't want to
leave it like this, and we said
that we wanted to fix this
broken functionality.
But apart from this, we also
knew that we wanted to go
towards something that a modular
and expenseable from the
architecture point of view.  But
the thing is that Plaid was
developed as an UI sample, not
as an architecture sample.
So you won't be surprised to see
all the dependencies in the code
and, well, code that was
actually a bit behind, because
Nick started building this in
2014.  At that time, we didn't
have the guide to that
architecture that we released
last year.  And also, although
we have Kotlin, we doesn't
really use it.  So we knew that
we wanted to rebuild Plaid and
in the right way.
So to have it in a good state
for any future changes that we
wanted it build.
So in this talk, I wanted to
tell you what we've learned and
how we managed
to leverage calls in our
app.  We released this guide to
the app architecture, and it is
still quite vague.  So we have
these main classes, some idea
for how we should architect our
app, but we wanted to create
clear guidelines.  So we defined
main types of classes in our app
and we also defined a set of
rules for each one of these
classes.  So we defined a remote
data source, whose role is
actually just to store the
request data, fetch the data
from the API service.  And
that's it.
We could request information and
return the response received.
Next, we would have a local
data source, whose role is just
to store data on disk.  So you
can either do this in shared
preferences, or in the database.
Next, we would have the
repository whose role is to
fetch and store data.  And,
optionally, it could also do
in-memory cache.  So the
repository will be the class
that mediates between the local
and the remote data source.
Because the business logic was
quite complex, we decided to add
another layer: Use cases.  So
the role of the use cases is
just to process databased on
business logic.  This will be
small, lightweight classes that
can be reused.  So the use cases
depend on repositories and/or
other use cases.
And next, we would have a
ViewModel.  So the ViewModel's
role is to expose data to be
displayed by the UI, and also to
trigger actions based on the
user's actions.
And the ViewModel would depend
on use cases.
As an input, the ViewModel would
give IDs.  It would give IDs in
the case where it is a model for
a detail screen, for example,
and it would give the user's
actions an an input.  And
output, it would return a
LiveData.
And next in the UI, we would
work with activities in XML.  So
the role of these is just to
display the data and to forward
actions to the ViewModel.
As an input, they would get the
optional ID and the user's
actions.
So we looked at our application,
or the architecture, and we
divided it into three layers:
The data, domain, and UI.  When
we decided to be more
opinionated in the way that we
use the libraries we are using.
We knew that the LiveData really
shines when it is used with an
activity or a fragment.  We
decided to really keep the
LiveData only between the
ViewModel and the UI, and that's
it.
And even more, was of the nice
integration between LiveData and
data binding, we decided to use
data binding in our XMLs.
But again, still with all of
these constraints and all of
these guidelines that we've set,
there are so many ways in which
we can actually implement this
kind of architecture.  And we
knew that Kotlin and the Kotlin
language features will help us
improve this even more.  And
more precisely, what we
particularly like are the
functional constructs that
Kotlin supports.  And one of the
first decisions that we have to
make is to handle asynchronous
operations.  And we decided to
work with coroutines as the
backbone of our app, with
coroutines, it is easy to launch
a Coroutine and handle the
response.  And more precisely,
what we liked is the fact that
coroutines have a scope.  So,
for example, let's say that you
are opening the activity, you
are triggering a network
request, you want to make sure
that when you are pressing back
and exiting that activity, you
are also cancelling that network
request.
So this scoping of it the
coroutines is something that we
liked.
So this meant that we decided
that, in the ViewModel, would be
the place where we are launching
and we are cancelling coroutines
and we are also making that
transition between coroutines
and LiveData.
But then, for all the other
layers above the ViewModel, we
would use suspension functions.
And these suspension functions
would return a result class.
So, more precisely, this result
will have two types: Success or
error.
And this is because we wanted to
make sure we are not throwing
exceptions here and, there but
that the errors represent a
state.  So what is interesting
in Kotlin is that if you want to
be able to ectend the class, you
have to market  mark it as open.
This means that classes are
final by default and you have to
be intentional when using
inheritance.  That means that
Kotlin supports the idea, the
best practice of favoring
composition versus inheritance.
But we can do better than using
open classes.  We can use a
sealed class, because with a
sealed class, we can restrict
the class hierarchies.  That
means we cannot extend the class
outside this file.
So a lot of times when we would
use this result class, we would
typically use it
inside a with, it has smart
casts, when there's a success,
you do something, when it is an
error, you do something else.
But every time we were using it,
we wanted to make sure that we
were always handing every case
and making sure that by mistake
we are not handling something,
we wanted the compiler to tell
us that, hey, you forgot
something, you forgot to handle
the error case.  This meant that
the when needs to be exhaustive.
But when is exhaustive only when
used as an expression.
So we added, we created the
exhaustive property.  So more
precisely, we created an
extension property where we are
returning the object.
Here's another problem that we
have.
So we have a comment class and a
comment with replies.  So the
difference between these two,
and the fact that the comment
also holds the information about
the user that posted the
comment.  So it will have the
display name and the portrait
url, and the comment with
replies is pretty much a tree
structure that holds the replies
of the comment and the replies
of the replies and such.  What
we had to do was to build a
comment out of the comment with
replies and a user object.
So you said, okay, that is easy,
create a new constructor that
gets the parameter, the user,
and the comment with replies and
that is it.  But the thing is,
we didn't really like this
because the classes were in two
different layers, why should the
comment know about the comment
with replies, why shouldn't it
know about the user? Why should
we need to changes this.htm? So
what weep ended up using is an
extension function.  So more
preciseprecisely, we built an
extension function to the
comment with replies, and that
will create a comment.  So when
you are building an extension
function, you only have access
to the public fields.  So this
means that we're not, by
mistake, accessing or changing
any private implementation and
it allows us to keep our classes
focused on what they do without
extending them.
And so it meant that we didn't
have to college the public API
and we would avoid accessing
private implementation details.
So what I like about data
classes is the fact that they
are value objects, this shines
when used in tests.  So for
example, we had an out vote flag
in the comment.  So when we
checked the test to see if it
was up voted, it would have it
to false, would upload the
comment and check whether the
expected result is similar to
the initial comment, but with
that up voted flag to true.  And
because the comment has so many
fields, it is easy to make
mistakes and what is actually
important here, the fact that
the up voted flag has changed.
With Kotlin, you can use the
copy method.  We create a copy
of the orbital and -- that it is
called on, and we are setting
the flag, the flag that we are
actually changing.
And that's it.  The code is more
concise and more readable, more
comprehensible.
So let's take another example.
So we had another, in the app,
we are working with a remote
data source to post a comment.
And here, we would expose the
suspension function that return
a result.  And inside this
method, we would create a new
comment request, which would
trigger that request in the
back-end, we would await for the
response, and then we would
handle the response, building
the results success, or the
result  result of error,
depending on what is needed.  If
you look at this code, this is
actually not enough.  In the
case when your device is
offline, this code will crash.
So what we had to do is to run
up every request inside a
tricatch, and we had a lot of
requests.  So we saw that we
keep on adding and adding this
tricatch everywhere, and then
our methods were loaded so we
couldn't really focus on what
really mattered on building the
response, triggering the
request.
So what we did is create a
top-level function.  So this
would  would be a suspending
function with a Lambda or the
error message.  Here, it would
trigger the code, wrap it inside
a tricatch, in the case of an
exception or result of error,
based on the error we passed in.
So this means that in the null
data source, we could just
create a safe API call and then
put the call that matters for us
inside another function.
The code became more readable
and easy to understand.
So this safe API call, I was
saying that it has the call as a
first parameter and the error
message as a second one.  In
Kotlin, if you -- if the last
parameter of a method is a lam
it Lambda, it means that you can
use it as a trailing Lambda.
That meant that when you are
calling this, instead of passing
these two parameters, we can
just pass the error members of
the jury as a parameter of the
function and then use the
trailing syntax to call the
method.
So like this, the code becomes
more concise.  But it is more
readable, so when we looked at
this, it felt like what matters
here the most is the error
message, which is not really
the case.  What mattered is we
get the first comment.  So
although the code is more
concise, it doesn't mean more
readable.  So brevity is not
necessarily a good thing.  If
Kotlin offers all of these
features, be mindful and think
of whether you need all of
these, and use them in the right
places.  This is another
example.
So, as soon as we were switching
to Kotlin, in the activities,
the first thing that we did is
make all of the views latant,
becausewy  we didn't want all of
the nullability.  We looked at
the code and saw that we
shouldn't do this.  Some views
are no result views, or only
inflated when specific
conditions are met.
So actually nullability was
good, nullability can be
meaningful.  Nullability was
telling us that something is
missing and that we should
really handle it.
So,
overall, all of these features
from Kotlin, like coroutines can
help us shape our app.  And
together, with the guide to app
architecture, help us build this
maintainable, this safer and
faster to develop architecture
that we wanted to have.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
1Y50IRK9SDS
Coming up next: Getting the Most
from the New Multi-Camera API by
Emilie Roberts, Oscar Wahltinez,
Vinit Modi  .
SPEAKER: Hi, everyone, welcome
to this session on the new
multi-camera
API.  I'm vinit ModModi.
I will give an update on the
state of camera.  Most camera
apps focus on the native camera
app that ships with the device.
More than twice the amount of
usage occurs on the apps that
you build.  And it is extremely
important that you support the
new features that are available
in the new
Android APIs.  When we speak to
a lot of developers, the number
one question is the state of
camera 2 API and where we are
going forward.  Starting with
Android P, you will find that
almost new devices will support
camera 2 and HALv3.  You will
see that the characteristics are
unlimited, like a point and
shoot, a full, with advanced
capabilities, and level 3, with
YUV processing and raw.
We are working with several
manufacturers to open new APIs
at launch.
We're excited that the pixel 3
and the HAUWEI20 series support
the API.
Why is this so important? Prior
to Android P, as developers, you
get access to one of the center
sensors and the native app the
whole capability.  We have the
native camera app, with the
sensor and the logical camera,
an abstraction of all of the
physical sensors that allow you
to take advantage of the
hardware.
There are several use cases and
possibilities with the new
multi-camera API.  Today, Oscar
is going to talk about optical
zoom and Emilie is going to
cover bouquet.
SPEAKER: I'm in thethe.
SPEAKER: I'm on the developer
relations team, and we will
start with the live
demo.  What could go wrong.  Are
we on?
Nope.
Here we are implementing the
multicamera zoom.  We are
swapping, at the UI layer, the
two camera streams and not doing
any kind of zoom or cropping.
And you can see it is
instantaneous, and this is just
a single session.
And I'm swapping the two camera
streams.
And I have the same thing here
on the pixel phone, and the main
idea is that you can see it is
working on -- if it works
again.
Had this been working, you would
see the same demo.
[ Laughter ].
In any case.  We will go back to
the
same slides.
The idea is that the single
camera session, to the streams,
we are going to swap between the
streamsstreams and show you how
it was built.  We have the same
running on both devices, a feat
to have them on both devices
something that is tied to the
hardware and the camera.
So we will talk about how we can
use multiple cameras
simultaneously, the basic
guarantee provided by the API is
that you can use two streams at
the same time.
Recall the guaranteed stream
configurations for single camera
devices.  It is a set of rules
based on higher level, target
type, and size.  If we use the
multi-camera APIs correctly, we
can get an exception to these
rules.
We will illustrate it with an
example.  We have a single YUV
stream of maximum size.  As to
the previous table, devices with
minimum hardware level will be
able to use a single stream
without configuration.  If we
use the multi-camera APIs, we
can use two streams of
equivalent configuration from
the underlying physical
cameras.
Let's walk through what we are
going to do to implement the app
we demoed earlier.  We broke it
into five steps.  Are you ready?
Step number one, find the
physical cameras.  We start by
defining pairs of physical
cameras that can be operated
simultaneously.
Using the subject, we look for
test capabilities.  If logical
multicamera is one of them, we
know this device is a logical
camera.  And now that we found a
logical camera, we store it, we
will need the ID for later, we
will see.  We get the physical
cameras associated with it.
And then we can move on to the
next step.
Here are some steps for what I
just described.  You take the
logical camera, you call get
physical camera IDs, and we
create the physical cameras
associated with the eligible
camera group.
On to the next step: Open
logical camera.
The second step is nothing new,
open the camera.  Recall the
camera ID we set earlier, that
is the only one we use to pass
to the camera manager.
To reiterate, we only open the
logical camera.  This triggers
whether the device is ready.
We have now opened logical
camera.
In the next step, we will create
the applicable configuration
updates.  They are used to
create the camera session.  For
each desired target, we may have
a physical camera from the list
we found earlier if we want to
retrieve frames from a specific
camera.  We will go into more
details.  We create the output
configuration object, using the
desired output target.  If we
want to associate that output as
a specific physical camera, then
we pass the AD in the set
physical camera ID API.  If
we want to use eligible camera,
we can skip this step.  We also
may is have a configuration of
both.
So, at the end of the day, we
have a list of configurations,
some of which are associated
with physical cameras, and some
of which logical camera.  The
goal is to put all of the
configurations into a single
session  session configuration.
Each configuration as an output
target and a physical camera ID.
Now we create the capture
session.
How do we create the capture
session using the new session
configuration object?
We start off with our list of
output configurations that we
just created.
With that, we instantiate
assessing configuration, which
includes the capture session
callback.
From that callback, we are going
to give the instance of the
creative camera session.
We take that session
configuration object, and the
camera device, which we got from
a step number two when we opened
the logical camera, and we send
that framework to the request to
create a new session with the
desired configuration.
The callback provided in the
session configuration object
will be triggered now, and then
we will have our camera session
ready to be used.
Last step, capture
requests.
Once that has happened, we can
start getting frames out of the
cameras.
For example, you want to capture
a frame from two physical
cameras simultaneously.  We take
the session we created earlier
and the pair of output targets,
and each is associated with a
specific camera ID.
We create a capture request that
we don't normally do, in this
case, we send to output preview.
We attach the output targets to
it that we normally do.  And now
we dispatch the capture request,
nothing different here, except
in this case the output services
will receive image data from
each of the associated physical
cameras and the capture request
callback will trigger only once.
So again, it is just like any
capture request, the big
difference is that the
completion callback will give me
back two start exposure time
stamps instead of just a single
value from normal capture
requests.
So to recap, this is how I
implemented the optical zoom
demo.  We found the physical
cameras, we opened the logical
camera that is part of the
group, we created the output
configurations, we planted the
list, created the capture
session, and then we distached
the capture
requests.
One more topic I wanted to touch
on is lens distortion.
A classical example of lens
distortion is the fish eye lens,
this is for illustration
purposes only.
All lenses have some amount of
disdistortion.  For logical
cameras, that is minimal and
corrected by the drivers.  For
physical cameras, the distortion
can be significant.  The
physical lens distortion is
described in a set of radial and
tangential coefficients, using
the lends distortion key.  The
commentation has a lot more
details if you are interested.
The good news is that
there's a way to correct
distortion without doing a lot
of math, you can set the
correction mode on a capture
request.  And off means that no
distortion is applied.
We may need to use this if you
want to do things like
synchronization, we may touch
oon it later.  And fast meanses
the corrections are applied
while meeting the target frame
rate.
High quality means that the
distortion is corrected as much
as it allows, potentially at the
cost of frame rate.  If we do
not specify a correction mode,
it is fast or high quality, to
the implementation details which
is default.  You can see which
is applied to your capture
request.  We will demonstrate
how this is set to high quality,
probably what we want for a
still ImageCapture.
Assuming that we are restoring
the camera captureception, we
instang
instantiate it.  And then we
determine if the high quality
distortion mode is available.
And now that we know that we
have high-quality correction for
the distortion, we settled on
the capture request, and we do
what we always do, pass the
capture
request.
For more sample code and
caconical details, take a look
at the blog post.  We covered
this and some more, we posted
earlier this week, and now we
will hand it over to Emilie.
SPEAKER: Thanks, Oscar.
I'm emilie Roberts, and I will
use this on
the bokeh effect.  And the first
has no camera at all, I will
show the mechanisms for creating
the bokeh effect.  When you get
into the dual cam, we can focus
on the multicamera aspects and
not worry about the bokeh
effect.  It will be published,
open source, don't worry about
scribbling too much code.  So
can we go to this
phone?
Okay, so we have -- I didn't set
this up properly.  We will do
the single cam bokeh effect, you
can see on the screen, cutting
me out, bump up the final
result, it is pasting the
portrait mode in there.  This is
a rough cut portrait mode. And I
have an optimization on this,
let's see how that goes.
I will show you the output steps
here.
So it is trying to do a better
job of finding the fore ground,
it didn't do too bad.  It is
generating the fore ground
image, the background, which is
just
let us down, pasting on the
final result.
So that is not too bad for a
single cam.
Let's try the dual cam demo.
With these stage lights, I'm not
sure.  C'mon.
Hey, not too bad.  We are doing
good.
So you can see a depth map was
created in the bottom left-hand
corner that is detecting me in
the fore ground, and the rest of
you are a little bit faded out,
you can see that closer folks
are in gray and the black to the
back.  You can see the lights
wreaking havoc, I will show you
the final result.  There's a few
optimizations that can happen.
But it is working pretty well.
So again, this is using the two
front cameras on the pixel two.
You can see the two streams
going at
once, oops.
Will this connect back up? Both
streams at once, the wide and
the normal angle going at the
same time.  Can we head to the
slides, please.  Let's talk
about how we do that, there we
are.  So we had the normal
camera and the wide angle
running at the same time.  We're
going to publish this probably
on GitHub, open source, so you
can dig into it and help
optimize it and make it better.
So the single cam, the floating
head bokeh effect I call it.
We're going to take a photo,
face detect, two copies, we have
background, fore ground, do
fancy background effects, and
paste the floating head back
where it belongs.  Face detect
is built into the camera 2 API,
easy to implement.  We will
check the camera characteristics
to see if the camera supports
face detect.  If it does, you
find the mode you want.  There
is off, and then simple, and
full, depending on your camera
device.  And then when we make
our camera capture request, we
will include that in the
request.  When you get our
results, you can see if the mode
was set.  If you found any
faces, in this example, I
searched for the first face that
it finds is the one that I use.
We can use this to expand
multiple faces.  And face detect
grabs the face.  So I bumped up
the bounds a little bit so it is
more of a head getting chopped
off, that sounds bad, a head
pasted on to the background.
And let's talk about the fun
background effects.
You can do what you want, using
render script, we did a blur.
Because it is a multi-camera
talk, some have a zoom, you can
do a background with another
camera and zoom it out of focus
so you can do an optical blur
and save you the software step.
And in this demo, we did a
custom software sepia effect
using render script.  If you are
using multicam, a lot of cams
have built in effects, like mono
chrome that you can query and
capture.  If you are not used
render script, it looks like
this.  For the blur effect, we
care about the three middle
lines and there's a built-in
script intrinsic blur, pretty
handy, and it basically works
outside of the box.
In this case, it blurred outside
of the box because the box is
not blurry, ha.  This is a
custom render script script for
the sepia effect.  You can see
in the first three lines, we are
taking the input red, green, and
blue channels, muting the
colors, making them yellow, and
setting those to the output
channels.
Okay, so we have the background,
a cool effect on it, what do we
do with the fore ground? We have
the face cut out and we apply
the border dev with the linear
gradient so when we paste it,
there is not the harsh line.
And ta-da, we paste it on,
things look pretty good.
There's a couple of
optimizations.  One you saw,
which is with the grab Cut
algorithm, built into open CV,
the computer vision library for
the depth map demo later on.
And basically, I found the -- I
chose a rectangle a bit lang
larger to guess where the body
might be, and then you have the
magic wand tool in the photo
editor to shrink it down.  And
then we can add in multiple
faces.
Now, the moment you have all
been waiting for, we will talk
about dual cam bokeh with the
depth map.  We're going to use
two cameras simultaneously, and
we're going to create a depth
mapmap, the hard part, which is
why I highlighted that in bold.
We will use the same mechanism
we talked about.  How does this
work? First of all, the double
capture.  So this, on the left,
is me hanging out with my pets.
The left is the normal camera,
the pixel 3, and the right is
the wide-angle shot.
To do that, just as Oscar one
walked through, we set up
multiple output configurations.
For each lens, we set up, here,
we have the preview surface and
the image reader for the normal
lens.  We use set physical
camera ID to the normal lens and
we do the same thing for the
wide angle lens.  So we end up
with four output configurations
we are putting into our con
figeration.  From there, it is a
matter of choosing output
targets for the capture.  We
want the photos, so we want the
image reader from the normal or
wide-angle lens.
Okay, so we have our images, and
now we have to do a bunch of
math and magic and make that
boket effect happen.  I want to
give a brief introduction to
stereo vision before we get into
the code.  Looking at these
slighted  slides y , I got
bored.  I like geometry, and I
started asking, what does P
stand for, anyway? Obviously it
is a pile of chocolate.  P
stands for pile of chocolate,
this is what we are focusing on
for the rest of the demo.  And
camera one is a little bit
boring, camera two.  So as here,
we are going to replace with a
character, this is my friend,
pepper the shark, and this is
hippo, that are going to help us
talk about stereo vision.  So
left camera normal lens is
pepper the shark, and right is
Suzie lou, the hippopotamus.
And they are zeroing in on that
chocolate.  And the skewed
rectangles there, the 2D
surface, the image that the
cameras are going to capture.
The 2D representation of the
real-live 3D object we have.
Let's look at what that look
like.  The shark eye view is on
the almond, and the hippo is on
the crunch.  They have this 2D
representation and we will take
their separate views and combine
them so we get a little more
information than the 2D view and
create a great depth map.  So we
have that, again, the normal
view, the wide-angle view, in
this case, they are both normal.
The left and the right hand, the
overlay on each other, and you
get that 3D ruler effect from
elementary school that you hope
you got to enjoy as a child.
And, from there, we can create a
depth map, which allows you to
do really cool things, like
awesome bouket effects, know how
far away the chocolate is so you
can reach out and grab it.
Okay, so those two cameras,
those two pictures are at a
different orientation from each
other and they are separated in
space.  So we need to get those
on top of each other.  This is
what we call the camera
extrinsics, how the cameras
relate to each other.  So we
need to rotate and translate the
images so they appear on top of
each other.  Normally we say --
we normally give the rotation
and translation parameters in
camera in relation to world.  So
instead of camera one to world,
we will have shark to world, and
hippo to world.  But when we are
doing stereo vision, we need to
worry about shark to hippo.  How
are the cameras related to each
other.  Like a good engineer, I
need to switch helpo hippo to
world and I have a pathway,
shark to world to hippo.
You can see the math on
Wikipedia, and it looks
something like this.  To get the
rotation matrix, we will reverse
it for camera two and
cross-multiply it with camera
one.  And we will take the inner
product and subtract.
You can read all about it on
Wikipedia or other sources.  If
you are working on this
yourself, work on the
translation matrix from pixel 3
from the normal to the wide
camera.  What do you notice
about this? The 9 millimeter
separation between the cameras
looks just about right.  If you
look at the phone, you know
there's a good, what is the
American, a good -- anyway.
There's a good nine millimeters
between those cameras, that
makes sense.  What I didn't
notice, it cost me about a week
of time, it is in the Y
coordinates.  The cameras are on
top of each other.  So while I'm
working on this phone, looking
at the cameras beside each
other, I assumed that they are
horizontally displayed, but it
assumes that they are right next
to each other.  And camera
sensors are often optimized for
landscape, which makes sense.
If you do it wrong, your depth
maps don't work, you pull your
hair out and have a great week
like I did.  Just a note when
implementing this.  So you have
the camera extrinsics, how to
get the pictures from the camera
on top of each other.
Intrinsics are properties of the
cameras themselves.  We have a
normal and a wide angle lens and
they have different properties.
So there are two things, the
camera characteristics, the
focal length, the principal
access, if that is skewed, this
appears often in the three by
three matrix, and distortion.
The lens, you are going to get a
little bit of distortion going
on that we need to consider as
we are mapping the two images
together.  And another note, we
will use the distortion
properties of the lens.  But the
camera undistorted it for
you.
We will undistort it and
redistort it, turn it off if you
want to do depth maps.  That is
easy for the request, make sure
the distortion mode is off.
Okay, here are the four things.
Rotation, translation, the
camera characteristics matrix
and the lens distortion.  How do
you get these properties? Easy.
You take an afternoon, print out
a checker board, has anyone done
this before? It is fun.
Camera calibration.  Take a
series of shots with both the
cameras, run a bunch of
algorithms, figure out these
four camera characteristics and
then you can start making depth
maps from the cameras.  You can
tell from my cheerful face that
it is not that fun, don't do it,
it is no good.  Luckily in the
camera 2 multicamera APIs, we
have these great fields:
Rotation, calibration,
translation, and distortion.
You can get it out the API which
is wonderful.  If you are
implementing this yourself, so
the camera characteristics, the
focal length, and the access
information comes in five
parameters.  This is in the
Android documentation.  But to
create that three by three
matrix, you have to follow the
documentation and plugin the
numbers.
Another thing that might throw
you off are the distortion
coefficients, the five values,
and the open CB value library
uses them differently than out
of the API.  You need to
remember it is 0-1, 342.  If you
use them in the 01234 order,
when you undistort your images,
they lack like look like they
are in a whirl pool.  So there
is something wrong with the
coefficients.
After the parameters, we
prepare the images to do a depth
map comparison.  This is me in
my kitchen, yes or no if I don't
know if you can see, but from
the ceiling, there's a curve
going down, the distortion
effects we are talking about
with the distortion correction
off.  And when you are comparing
two images, the straight and
curved lines need to line up.
We call that rectifying and we
use the camera characteristicses
characteristicsesx to do that.
All of the functions are in the
open CV library.  The first is
stereo rectify, it gives a set
of parameters to define these
calculations.  We pass in the
values we got from the API, the
camera matrix, the distortion
coefficients, the rotation and
translation that we calculated
before.  We get these parameters
out, we call undistort rectify
map, which gives us a map
telling us how we can take two
images from these cameras and
map them to each other.  And the
remap function does just this.
So lets see what that gives us.
.  On the left again, from the
normal cam, front cam of the
the pixel three and the wide
angle lens.  You can see that
the lines are lined up, the crop
is right, the roof lines, the
door lines are straight, there
is no whacky distortion, from
where you are sitting, you
probably have to look closely to
notice that the left-hand
picture is a little bit closer
to the left-hand side of the
frame.  So there are actually --
they are offset by a little bit
which is what you would expect
if you had two cameras nine
millimeters apart.
So we have the images, we have
undistorted it and rectified
them and we are close to
creating the depth maps, we call
the depth map function.  We use
stereo BM, or stereo SGBM.  One
has a few more parameters than
the other.  When you play with
the open source demo, you can
see how these parameters work
and play around with it.
Optimize them.
Commit your changes.
Help make that better.
We call compute and make the
step map.  When you do this, you
get an amazing photo, something
like this.
And actually, sometimes it looks
a lot better than that.  This is
not quite what we want to work
with.  We want to filter that,
in this case, using the weighted
least squares filter, that
smooths it out and gives more
useful depth map.  So the darker
pixels are farther back, and the
whiter are the closer ones.  It
is hard to see, you can see the
shark's snout and the hippo's
snout are a little bit grayed
out, so it is actually working
to some extent there.  This is
what we call the filter, it is
also included in the open CV
libraries in the contributor
modules.  So it is all open
source.
And it is really cool when you
get a depth map that
isS per feck, it is
exhilarating.  So here we have
the depth map.
What do we do with it? We can
apply it as a mask on top of it,
and the black areas we want to
fade out and we want to
highlight the fore ground.
That is pretty easy to do with a
porter
def, and the result is something
like this.
So, Indeed, the fore ground is
more present and the background
is faded out.  I have high
standards, I see a translucent
floating shark over my shoulder,
my face is grayed out, my eye
ball is missing, I will put a
red X through it, not quite good
enough, but we want a depth map
more like this.  We will put a
hard threshold on it and decide,
fore ground, background, that is
it.  In either apps, you may
want to do something similar,
but it could be a smoother
curve.  To do that, we can use
the open CV function threshold.
We give it some cutoff value for
the app, it is somewhere around
80 to 140 out of 255, and that
is just that limit where
something is considered fore
ground or background.  I wanted
to note this in case you are
implementing any of this.  When
we applied the mask, you need to
turn the black pixles to
transparent, this converts all
of them to
transparency.  We are almost
there.  In the middle picture,
my eye is a bit blacked out.
Just remember that for three
more slides or so.
So we have the initial picture,
we have the depth map, we do
this hard threshold on it, and
we can again create our
background just like we did in
the first demo, blur it out,
mono, monoChrome it, and cut out
that fore ground.  We have all
the pieces we need to paste it
on.  This is our amazing, final
portrait shot.
Which -- that is pretty good.
I'm proud of it.
So we will talk about an
optimization.  And remember the
eye ball thing I was talking
about? So anything kind of
gleaming and shining can get
messed up in this current
iteration of the application, or
bright lights can throw off the
depth map.  I did one
optimization, we have the face
detect region.  I'm pretty sure
I want the face in the fore
ground.  So I used it and cut it
out and said anything in the
face is going to be the fore
ground.  So that protects it,
like my teeth and my eye from
the masking out effect.
I don't know if you noticed, we
will go back, my fuzzy red hair
and the red couch, it kind of
blended in.  So we can use grab
cut to do a little bit better
job of figuring out exactly what
is in the fore ground.
So thanks a lot, we really hope
that this gave you a deep dive
into using camera 2 and the
multi-camera APIs, and gave you
exciteg and creative ideas.  We
want to hear your ideas, see
them in the apps, and know what
features you are looking for.
We think they are great and we
want to keep pushing the camera
ecosystem forward and keep doing
more and more stuff
ecosystem-wide.
Thanks so much again and please
do come to the camera sandbox if
you want to ask us any
questions, follow-ups, try this
app, see if it works, look
forward soon to being open
source.  Thanks a lot.
[ Applause ].
SPEAKER: Now that leads us to
our final snack time of the
summit.  We have coffee and
snacks and coffee and fruit and
cheese and stuff like that for
you all.  But a few things I
want said ed to call your
attention to, please rate the
sessions so we have a QR code
that will come up here
momentarily, they are
incredible.  The team is just
amazing.  So this is how you
tell us how good of a job we
have been doing.  Let us know
what you think of our speakers,
our sessions, one other thing.
If youmissed sessions, all
sessions from yesterday are
online, and by the end of today,
every single session from today
is going to be online.  So you
can go home and binge watch all
of the things you didn't get to
see.
And, finally, come back and make
sure to come back.  We have
great sessions coming on later,
and in both rooms, we are not
quite done yet.  And enjoy your
snack break.
[ Applause ]
SPEAKER: [ Applause ].
>>> Hello, everyone. Welcome to
the deep dive into Android
Studio profilers session.  I'm
David Herman SPEAKER: I'm
Shukang Zhou.  We are developers
in the Android Studio.
SPEAKER: We wanted to guv you an
outline of what to expect in
this talk.  Instead of a high
overview, we will narrowly focus
on a few features that we think
can help you get a better handle
on any code base.  We will drop
some tips and tricks along the
way.  We are going to be
profiling a real app, Santa
Tracker.  It is an app by Google
which allows users to track
Santa on his course around the
world on Christmas Eve.  The app
also contains games and a couple
of other extras.  We are -- they
release a new app every year.
We're using the one that is
publicly available on GitHub.
Finally, I want to mention two
talks about profilers that are
previously given this year, one
at Google I/O that did talk
about profilers at a higher lef,
also introducing what is new in
Android Studio o3.2, and the
other at the Android gamedev
summit about profiling your game
.  That talk focuses on
performance, native code,
related tools, things like that.
You can find those vade  --
videos on YouTube.  If you are
watching this online, we
included the links in the
description below.  If this is
your first time coming and
learning about profilers, you
are just curious, here's a quick
overview.
The studio profilers feature is
divided into four main
profilers, one for CPU, one for
memory, one for network, and one
for battery.
There's also an event profiler
that is on the top of -- that is
always on the top, which lets
you see things like user events,
such as taps, keyboard events,
screen rotations, and life cycle
events.  So when your fragments
and activities start and stop.
That's enough talking, let's
jump into the demo.
SPEAKER: Okay.
Let's start the demo.
So first, we want to click on
this button.  I can launch the
app, and I will start the
profilers.
And so today, we are using
Android Studio 3.4, canary 3,
because that's the latest
version of what we have.
Since the canary release is not
a stable release yet, so there
might be some bugs, please bear
with us if anything interesting
happens today.  The app we are
using today, the Santa tracker,
contains only Java code.  So the
Java apps will be the focus of
today's talk.
So, as you can see, in the we
have four
profilers: CPU and energy.  You
can click on any one of them to
get more data.
We will jump to the CPU
profiler.  Here, as you can see,
in the CPU profiler, you can see
the CPU utilization and the
thread state.  They are useful
to tell you when your app
becomes CPU bundled.
And if you are examining two
related threads, one trick is
here, you can reorder the
threads any way
you want.
To know further data information
about which path of your code is
executing or how they are
executing, you need CPU
recordings.
And let me get a little bit more
space.  So, as you can see here,
there are four types of CPU
recordings.  So we will go to
the first one, called Java
methods.  We will get a quick
recording of this one.
So during this type of CPU
recording, the Java virtual
machine is theoretically we
collect the core stacks of all
the Java threads in your
process.
And then it will present the
stacks in the -- in this part,
which we called the recording
details -- the details of the
recording.
And, after the recording is
done, the entire recording is
automatically selected and if
unit to  -- you want to take a
closer look, there's a button
called zoom tool selection.
So if I click on it, it will
fill the entire screen.  And if
you want to just see a sub range
of the recording, you can select
using the mouse.  If you want to
select the entire recording, you
can click on this small clock
icon here.
And,
a very specific point.  In that
case, you can do a single click
in this area and you can
automatically select something
here.
Now let's take a look at the
call stacks here, and let's
select this range that might be
more interesting.
So, as you can see, the profiler
will color the cost from the
Android platform in orange, the
method from the Java language in
plu,- blue, and it will color
any of your code in the library
to green.  So if you want to
know what method from your code
is running, you will be looking
for the green stuff.  So here we
see some green stuff here and
here, you can see, this is an
on-call method from the village
view class.  And if it is not --
if you see the code base, you
can easily see the shield is
responsible to draw the cloud
that is on this
screen.
So another thing I want to talk
about the sampling is you can do
some justm customization about
the recording time.  You can
click the edit configuration
entry, you can create the
customized CPU configuration.
For this Java method recording
type,
rue can change the inter
intervales.  The more quickly
you select samples, the more
quickly the data will be
represent said ed to you.  That
will incur more overicide. Head.
Depending on the use case, you
want several tries until you
find the sweet shot.  As we have
seen, the sample Java method is
very useful to get a very
high-level picture of which part
of the code it is running.  In
some other scenarios, if you
want to focus on a smaller area,
the second type of the
recording, trace Java method,
will be more interesting.
So let
me collect another trace.
So in this type of CPU
recording, the Java virtual
machine is selecting the  --
collecting the data every time
it executes a method.  So
there's a lot more data being
collected.
And so I wanted to understand
what method from my code is
running, then you wanted to look
for the screen stuff here.  You
can see that there's a lot of
things, you want to zoom in.
You can use the WAS keys to zoom
in.  So the W is the zoom in,
you can see with the key I'm
pressing.  The S is zoom out,
the D is moving to the right,
and A is moving to the left.
So if you are gamer, you
probably know this.
So if you zoom in, let's see
what are the green stuff.
So a big one is the one that we
just saw observe, the methods
from the village view.  And they
are responsible for drawing the
clouds.  And here is the method
from the snowflake view class,
they are responsible to draw all
of the snow flakes that are
floating around.  If you look
closely, there are many tiny
green lines here.
So you can further zoom in, you
can further zoom in, you can see
-- I will zoom in.
So you can see that this is the
method from the snowflake class,
and this is also from the snow
flake class, this is also from
the snow flake class.  So let
let's -- you may
want to see what data  source
this goes.  So you can jump to
the source code.
You can see in the snow flake
class, on this method, we are
doing some calculation about the
velocity about the angle, about
the size, and then we draw and
it is very clear that every line
of this screen will execute the
method.  That is why we are
seeing so many calls into this
method.
So ass as
So ass as you can se you can
see, you can see what is
executed and how often it is
executed.
And another thing I want to talk
about here is the chats here.
The first is the call chat, that
is representing all of the call
stacks during the CPU recording.
So it is -- the things to the
left, well, we will select the
entire range so you can see.
So the call stacks on the left,
it is what happens first in this
recording.  So the things to the
right, they will happen later in
this recording.  In the frame
chart, it is similar to the call
stack, but it is upside down.
So the root is on the bottom,
and also, identify call stacks
aggregated here.
So it is very easy to see the
total time the method has been
executed.  The
top-down, it has exactly the
same data as the frame chart.
It is just represented in a
different view.
What is nice about this view is
you can sort these methods by
the time.  So the sales time is
the sime executing by this
method itself, the children is
executed by the sub routines
called by this method, and the
total time is a combination of
the two.
Bottom-up is looking at the call
stack upwards to the caller,
basically from the method to
another
function, to that call.
So you can see it is very useful
to see where this method is
called and how much time this
method has executed when it is
called by that specific color.
And there is a third type of CPU
recording that is called related
functions, C or C++ functions.
We will do another trace here.
And if you remember, I just said
that this app, the Santa
tracker, it contains Java, only
code.  So therefore the call
stacks, assuming it is corrected
by this type of recording, it is
not very interesting.  They are
mostly the system calls, and
some of them are in the Android
framework native code.  If your
app has any native components,
this type of recording will be
very handy.
There is another type of CPU
recording called trace system
cost, and before I go into the
details of that, I will head
back the
demo back to Dave.
SPEAKER: CPU recordings are very
useful.  Sometimes there's an
exact function, or maybe a
couple ofphic  functions you
want to analyze and it is a
little bit imprecise to record,
do something in the app, stop
recording and zoom and search
for it.  We provide a very
simple solution for
this.  And I added the code in.
So we will talk about it.  The
debug class is a part of the
Android API, and the debug class
and many of it's methods have
been in the Android API since
the first version, including
these two.
What the start tracing method
function does is it asks the
system to take a trace, save it
with the file name, and it saves
it later so you can pull it up
on the device later.  We will do
all of that work for you.
So if you are doing this
manually, you probably would be
very careful about the name that
you chose, if you are doing
multiple chases, you would
choose unique names so they
didn't override each other.  In
our case, the name is not going
to show up in studio, so call it
CHARFBT  whatever you want.  I
will put a recording around the
function.  So in this case,
there's an activity in the Santa
Tracker, the CD quiz which loads
files from the disk.  That's
really good if you want to know
how long it is going to take, if
it is suspicious, we want to
take a look.  When you call the
start method tracing function,
it is going it to do a trace of
your code.  This more expensive,
precise detailed one.  I would
be careful, I wouldn't do this
around a large amount of code,
just to make sure it doesn't
take longer than you would which
is down here.  We willexpect.
We will go to the city quiz,
see what happens.  Before I do
this, I want you to keep your
eye over here in the session
panel.  I will hit play.
It is going to run in, it is
automatically recorded, you
don't have to do anything, that
is awesome.  Let me back utout.
As you can see here, there is
nothing new.
This is what Shukang was showing
you before.
And I think this is a good
moment to call out the life
cycle events I talked about in
the beginning of the talk.  As
you can see, we are doing a load
here.  We left the previous
activity and we are into a new
activity.  If you put your mouse
over an activity, as of Android
Studio 3.3, we will include the
fragments that are active during
that time.  That may be useful
for you.  But we are in this
space where we are loading
before we entered the activity.
And there's another really great
feature I want to show you here,
this filter button.  When I
press the filter button, it
brings up a search box, what I
type into it.  And I happen to
know that JSON has a function
called read literal, let me type
that in.  And one thing you
might notice here is that part
of my call chart dimmed out.
And all parts of here are not
dimmed, they are the normal
color.  I will zoom in and find
where that is.  So you can see
instances of the read literal
function.  And basically, if my
function is an exact match, it
will bold.  If it is a function
that calls either into that
function or is called out of
that function indirectly, the
color will be left the same, and
otherwise it will dim.  And it
is really useful to sort of get
a good overview of how much time
you are spending in your code on
the function that you care about
versus what you don't have to
pay attention to.  All of the
CPU detail views support this.
So the flame chart has the
similar dimming, the top will
strip out the functions that
were dimmed.  If you are trying
to inspect some sort of method
and you are narrowing down on
it, please give the filter
option a try and see if you can
sort of focus on what you are
looking at. And the last thing
to call attention to here is all
of the traces that you have
done, if you mouse over them,
there's a save button here, so
you can export your traces.  If
you do this, you can give it to
a co-worker, attach it to a bug,
useful things like that.  If
someone gives you a trace file
or you are loading it, you can
hit the plus button over here
and load it from file.  Okay,
cool.
SPEAKER: So now I'm going to
talk about the last type of CPU
recording, the trace system
cost.  And the trace system
cost, this feature was
introduced in Android Studio
3.2.  It collects fine-grain
system events related to app
performance so you can
investigate how your app
interacts with the system
resource.
So let's create the system
trace.
So I'm using the click to zoom
button here, it is easy to see.
And one thing I want to show you
here, the first thing I want to
show you is in this thread state
view.  If you
click the range, I will zoom to
that collection again.  I will
click here.
So here, as you can see, you can
use your mouse, you can hover
over and see this thread space.
It is running, and it is runable
and running again.  We are
collecting every CPU scheduling
operation.  At these levels of
details, it is easy for you to
figure out where your thread
becomes blocked.  And that could
be useful if you have some
threading issues.
And another thing that I want to
show using the trace system
calls is to investigate slow UI
chunk.
So slow UI rendering, also
called Jenk by some people.  As
you may know, that's the UI, the
Android UI, it does the work in
two phases: The first phase
happens in the main thread.  It
determines what is on the
screen, including the
layout and the source.  It
executes all of the UI elements,
such as all of the view classes
in your app.
So after the main thread
generates the what, they are
passed to the native render
thread.  The render thread will
be figured out how to draw them.
And then the how is passed to
the surface finger system
process, and the hardware that
is actually performing the
joins.
So that is giving that
background, so you can see under
the frame area, we have -- if
you pronounce the main thread,
the render is the render thread.
So let me zoom out a little bit.
So you can see here this -- this
the first phase, and
corresponding the second phase
will be here.
If you are targeting a smooth
UI, the smooth animation at 60
frames per second, which is 16
milliseconds, roughly 16
milliseconds per frame.  The two
phases combine together should
be under 16 frames.  If it is
longer than that, then the
profiler will color that frame.
So, you know, this is something
--.
So if you zoom out more, you
can see a lot of frames, I think
that
everyone today is red, so
exceeding the 16MS threshold.
One factor is that we are using
the emulator.  Because the way
the emulator interarcts with the
system, you are going to see
more red frames from the actual
device.  Before today's talk, I
have collected another trace
using a physical device.  I have
exported that trace as a file.
And now I want to import that
trace to show you.
So, as Dave said before, we can
use this to import
the trace.
And because when you trace the
system course, you need to tell
the profiler which process you
want to look at.  So if you want
to look at the static tracker,
as you know, the Linux from the
system point of view, every
process or every thread that
your name is no longer than 15
characters.  That is why this is
the Santa tracker.debug, for
some reason, it thinks this is a
name.  If you select this one,
you are going to import this
trace.  And here, you can see
from the actual device, most of
the frames will be in gray, and
that indicates they under 16MS
threshold.  Some of the frames
are in the red, because they are
over
that threshold.
And you may wonder how does the
system or the profiler know how
long the phases are taking.
That is from the trace in point.
So Android platform engineers
have added building tracing
points into the sum of the
critical tasks in Android
system.
So, I mean, the example here is
if you click the main thread
here, these events are showing
from the trace events here.
So if I zoom
in here, you will see this --
theseeral trace event called
choreographer two frame.  That's
the first phase in the UI
rendering, it happens in the
main thread.  If you click the
render thread, you can see there
that it is called a jaw frame.
That is the second phase.  You
can see that there are other
tracing points in the system.
They are all built in the
system, they are available on
any Android phones because they
are building.  They are useful
to get timing information for
specific tasks, and actually you
can have your own trace point,
too.  I'm going to demo that
here.  So today, here, if we go
to the top of the app, we have
the cloud, we have the snow
flakes.  I want to know how long
my code is spent drawing them.
So for the cloud, I go to the
village view.
So there should be an on draw
method.  So at the beginning of
the method, I add the
instrumentation, the trace
begin section, you need a
stream.  And at the end of the
method, we end the trace event.
For the snow flock  flakes, it
goes to the view, the on draw
method.  I want to point out the
section name, you should pick a
name that makes sense to you so
you can recognize when you are
doing the CPU recording.  Here,
we are doing the snow flake,
Android summit 2018.  That makes
sense for today's demo.
And so now, I will add the
manual instrumentation as we
view this app and reprofile it.
So while we are waiting for the
build, you may be wondering, if
I want to know how long those
two methods are taking, use the
trace Java methods.  That's what
we were talking about moments
ago.
So trace Java method is very
powerful, it is very easy to
use, but it has significant
overhead because the Java
virtual machine is collecting
data, every time when the
execution enters the method and
every time when the execution
acts on the methods.  So if you
have a lot of frequent, small
methods, that overhead can
quickly add up and become very
expensive.  If you use the
manual instrumentation, for
example, like the trace -- using
the trace API, you will have the
full console of where and when
to collect data.
So if you use that wisely, the
overhead will be much smaller
and, as a result, the data you
cleck  collected will be more
accurate.  So let's verify the
instrumentation you have.  You
go to the CPU profiler.  We
collect the trace
system calls.
And so here, this is the view
thread that is responsible for
all UI elements.  And if
you keep zooming, you can see
the village view, who is joining
the clouds, and this is a
snowflake -- what is responsible
for drawing the snow flakes.
This is the trace system called
CPU recording.  You may hear a
very similar tool, sis trace.
And my Google co-worker gave a
lightning talk yesterday on the
sis trace.  So it is an
extremely powerful tool, but the
learning curve of the sis trace
is a little bit steeper than the
Android Studio profiler.  So you
may choose the tools that best
suits your needs.  So I will
hand over the demo back to
David.
SPEAKER: All right.
So let's leave the CPU profiler
behind and jump over to the
memory profiler.
First of all, I want to draw
everyone's attention to this
allocation tracking pull-down.
Some quick history here, in
Android Studio 3.0, when
targeting devices with O or
newer, we collected a call stack
for every single allocation that
your app made.  We did it
because it would be convenient
to use to have that history,
however, some of our users
reported that profilers were
slowing their app down.  After
we investigated, it turned out
to be this feature.  So starting
in Android 3.3, we now give you
the option to configure this.
And let me go ahead and look
here.  So we have none, sampled,
and full.  None disables the
feature, null enables it, and
sample attempts to collect a
subset of the allocations that
would sort of gives you a
general look for how your
ach's memory behavior is,
without affecting the
performance as much.
And now, that being said,
without or not full affects your
app depends on the host machine
you are running on, whether you
are targeting the device, or the
code.  If your app code has a
lot of small allocations on it,
like Santa tracker does, it can
be slow.  But I recommend
playing with the features.  I
will go and turn full on.
So notice once I turned on full,
the allocation indicator started
showing up.  I wanted some
interesting things to happen so
I will rotate the
device.
So I will rotate it back.  We
will go and take a look here.
So all I need to do at any point
is just to drag across, and I
will be able to see all of the
allocations and the
de-allocations that happened
during that range.  This can be
a lightweight way to sort of get
a quick look at what your memory
is doing.  There is an
allocation and a de-allocation
count.  Sometimes you might find
memory leaks just doing this.
And the other nice thing is, if
you have this on and you are
doing other stuff, you can go
back in time and select a range
and still see what is going on
in memory.  I will go ahead here
and turn it back off again.
And you will notice that the
allocation indicated that it
stopped tracking by doing an
empty circle.  If I did sample
mode, it would put a half-filled
circle.  Now, looking at these
objects, once I click on it, you
can see every single one that is
currently allocated as well as
the -- where it was allocated.
This is very useful to get your
handle on a code base.  You can
click on this and see where the
different objects are coming
from.  That being said, it might
not help you understand why a
memory leak happened, what is
holding on to my memory.  If I
you want to get that
information, you have to go over
here to this icon and click the
heap done.  So what I'm going to
do here, just to let you know, I
could not find a leaking
activity or fragment in the
Santa tracker app.
So, full disclosure, I added
one.  And what I did is I added
a memory leak to this penguin
swim game here.  So actually we
will go ahead and go into the
app, or the activity, and leave
it.  And let me actually do
another heap dump.
All right.
So we're about to get a bunch of
heat dump information here.  I
know that the fragment inside
this activity is called swim
fragment.  Just like CPU, we
have the filter
button here.
And I can filter the different
objects and sure enough, the
swimming fragment is still
alive.  I will click on it,
select the active instance, and
there's a lot going on here.  So
I will take a moment  moment to
explain a little bit and take a
moment to absorb it.  I want to
explain what the depth idea is.
So imagine all of your Java
collector lives in this heap.
There are special objects that
live outside of the circle,
called GC roots.  When you
create a new thread, you create
the GC root, or the static
variables are an instance.  So
what ends up happening, you in a
thread might create an instance
of some class that creates inert
another instance of another
class and you are creating this
long chainf of objects and each
item in that chain has further
and further depth from the GC
root.  You may have heard that
cycles are not a problem to the
garbage collector.  I can point
at you, you at you, you at me.
If we cannot all be reached,
that is removed from the GC.  So
one of the things to note, if
you take a heap dump, you might
see a scary amount of things
holding on -- in my instance, a
lot of these are harmless.  A
lot of them are potentially just
cycles.  And one way that you
can kind of know, it is a good
heuristicheuristic, the depth is
greater than your own depth.  So
imagine the garbage collector
root points to you, you create a
child instance and one of the
things you do, you give it your
this pointer, it is pointing
back at you, you are pointing at
me, you are my child and know
who my parent is.  My depth is
going to be added on to this
pointer's depth.
So that's why some of these --
you are noticing it here, but it
is not an issue. And you are
seeing columns where the depth
is blank.  There is flow way to
reach these at the moment from
any garbage collection root T.
Will be cleaned up, even though
it is in the heap dump right
now, you don't have to where he
worry about it now.  Just ignore
it.  And just a concrete
example, I will look here at the
code which is not the cause of
our memory leak.  Our depth is
one, and this item's depth is
two.  So what this is saying,
somewhere there is an instance
of a score view class and that
score view class has a variable
called share/click/listener
whose value is me.
And we will go ahead and take a
look at swumming fragment.  And
I can search for the score view.
And before when I say this,
there has to be a score view
that points at me, and it is
inside the swimming fragment.
If I jump to it, I create one
and I pass in the this pointer.
So that is explaining why
there's a cycle there, I don't
have to worry about it and it is
explaining why it is showing up
in the heap dump.  And there's
lot of this dollar sign zero
symbols.  What is going on here,
you are going to see it a lot,
you know what the this pointer
is.  If you are an inner class,
or a nested class and you need
access to the outer class's
fields, the compiler generates a
synthetic variable and instead
of calling it this, because that
is taken, it is this dollar sign
zero.  That means that it is the
this, the one level out of my
scope.  And anytime you create
an inner class that has a
reference to the outer class, or
you create a closure and an
anonymous class instance, it is
going to have that.  If you are
using Lambdas in your code or
anonymous classes, you will see
a lot of zeros.  This has a
depth of zero, with a GC root,
that is suspicious.  We will
look at the source.  And I might
look at this and say, where  I
wrote this long running class.
It is not static, it is final,
and it will hold a reference to
the parent class.  That's what
is going on here, and this
long-running task, I created it,
but I forgot to cancel it.  We
will look here, sure enough, I
left it out, for no if reason.
I will uncomment it there and we
will re-launch.  So what we're
going to do now is, I will make
sure it is saved.  There we go.
What we're going to do now is
reboot it just to make sure
that, in fact, the swimming
fragment was released.  One of
the things to keep an eye out
for when you are hunting for
memory leaks is static variables
or singleton classes that are
holding on to your class, or
registering yourself with a
listener and for getting to
remove it, or any inner classes
that, for some reason, may not
end up stopping and they are
running even though the activity
is trying to exit.  Are we
profiling here? Yes.  We still
going.
And then another thing I want to
mention is it is not always
going to be this easy.  You are
not going have this obvious
culprit.  So, in that case, you
are going to want to -- I would
say just try to get to know the
code, look for those things that
I talked about, we will go ahead
and enter.
And we will wait here while I
talk.
And, you know, if you cleaned it
up, even if you didn't find it
in the heap dump, it is going to
be the source of truth.  It is
going to be the thing that
gar  guarantees your memory is
reclaimed.  So I will go back
into the memory profiler, click
on the garbage collector.  You
may have noticed these garbage
collected events, automatically
at the bottom.  So for example,
there's a lot there.  That's
where the garbage collector
decided to collect on its own.
And you can click the garbage
collection button to manually
cause it to get run.
And now we still see swimming
fragment here.  We will see if
the depth is actually -- as you
can see, the swimming fragment
is showing up I could be
nervous, but the depth column is
blank.  And everything else is
waiting to be picked up by the
GC.  You can press the garbage
collector a few more times.  And
one trick I like to do is rotate
the phone, rotate it again.  And
every time you rotate an Android
phone, a lot of fun things
happen, it tells the GC a lot of
things are going on.  We will
see the heap dump and assume
that it is truly well and
collected.  I wish it came with
a drum role, and  roll, and it
is gone.  If you are looking at
the heap dump, you are not
necessarily hunting memory leak,
you might not know a major class
to look out for.  There's the
concept of shallow size and
retain size.  Shallow size is
the size of a single instance of
some class that it have been
allocated.  And retain size is
all of the things that it is
holding on to.  So what you may
want to do is hunt, sort the
shallow and retain size and
investigate to see if there is a
suspicious memory thing there,
you can clean up your design and
remove memory there earlier.
So that ends the demo, and back
to Shukang.  Let's go to the
slides.
SPEAKER: So to recap, in today's
demo, we showed you how to use
CPU and memory profiler to get a
better understanding of the code
base for the Santa Tracker app.
To be honest, Dave and I don't
know much about it before we are
preparing for this talk.  And we
also have shown that we don't
only use profilers to diagonal
performance issues, we use them
to help us understand the
performance of this app.
And as we said before, there are
also network and energy
profilers in Android Studio, but
unfortunately we don't have time
to cover them today.  So these
refer to our online documents
and talks to learn more.
So we hope we have learned some
tricks and tips from our demo
today.  We hope that you  they
are useful when you approach
your own code base with Android
Studio builders at your side.
Thank you for attending our
talk.
[ Applause ]
SPEAKER: The next session will
begin in 10
minutes.
Coming up next: Testing Android
Apps at Scale with Nitrogen by
Stephan Linzner, Vishal Sethia.
#
Stephan Linzner, and back with
me
is Vishal Sethia.
And we develop products for
everyone, and that means we have
to test for everyone.  So let me
tell you a little bit about how
the development test happens at
Google.  Before I start, I want
to talk about the scale that we
do on Android development at
Google.  We have 100-plus
Android apps, including the user
apps such as Google photos,
maps, YouTube, Gmail, search.
We have 200 billion lines of
code, and run 20,000 Android
builds every day and have a
staggering 27 million test
innovationss -- invocations per
day.  How do we create these
high quality app and maintain
that quality over such a
long time?
An a typical developer workflow
looks like this.  We have a
strong code review culture, code
reviews are very, very thorough
and, before you can actually
submit your change or pull
request, you have to get at
lease reviewed by one of your
peers.  And another important
thing is all development happens
at head.  We have a large repo
that allows us to search for and
use code and create large-scale
changes.  And we also have a
very strong testing culture.  At
Google, if you have a change,
you have to have tests.
And even more importantly, all
of those tests have to pass
before you submit your change.
To run tests, you use a
large-scale distributed CI
system, which not only runs your
tests, but all of the testss
from code that depends on your
change. Another thing that is
very unique about Google is we
have a strong engineering
productivity culture.  That
means we have dedicated teams
that only work on infrastructure
tools and APIs to make
developers
productive.
We are part of such a team, and
we have been working on testing
Android apps, or Android app
testing, at Google.
So I want to take you a walk
down memory lane what we have
done at Google to scale Android
testing.
In 2011, a lot of teams at
Google actually started to build
for Android because Android was
becoming more and more popular.
They were using a standard tool
chain, ant and eclase.  And we
support said ed the internal
build system.  A problem that
was obvious early on is the need
for scalable testing.  We
started off very simple by
building a small host-like test
runner that would run on the
host.  And, in fact, it was a J
unit three test suite, list the
APK, list the tests, and give it
on the instrument test runner on
the device to execute the test.
And once we have that, we built
it into a continuous integration
system.  One of the key
decisions we made early on was
to use emulators, we called them
virtual devices, to run tests
alts at scale because it makes
more sense because you can scale
a data center, but not a USB hub
so easily.  So we wrote this
Python script, 200 lines of
code, you probably have been
there, that boots the emulator
for us that allows us to run the
tests and shout it down
afterwards.  While we were
working on infrastructure, our
engineers started to write
tests, and they wrote a lot of
them.  A key problem here is
around functional UI testing.
In the early days, you had
low-level framework APIs, you
are monitors to track
activities, or wait until idle
sink  sync.  And even though
these APIs were easy to use,
developers struggle a lot
writing reliable UI tests.  We
thought that maybe we can find
something better, and we did
in the community Robotium, and
we used them until 2012.  It had
issues bes with the API surface,
and it did not solve
synchronization.  We used
Espresso, we wanted something
easy for developers and handled
the complex instrumentation
testing from the developer.  We
had a decent set-up for
instrumentation tests, but we
have to solve the unit testing
problem.  At the time, all of
the unit tests, you ran them on
the device.  But that is
expensive and they tend to be
slower than running on the JVM.
So we reached for a solution,
which at the time was
RobolectricRobolectric.  It
allowed for fast local
development and is still one of
the most popular frameworks for
unit testing in Google.  In
2014, we build a lot of
experience in testing
APIs, but we were seeing that
the community was struggling
from the same problems that we
did.
So we bundled all of the
libraries together in the
Android testing support library
, the default library for
developers writing
instrumentation tests.
Fast forward to today, we
launched AndroidX test 1.0.  It
is not only the first stable
release, it is the first time
where we ship unified APIs that
allow you to write tests once
and run them anywhere.
And, by the way, we just
achieved a major milestone at
Google.  We run 10 billion unit
and instrumentation tests every
year on our infrastructure.
And so, looking back at those
seven years, what will go
differently? There's a couple of
things I want to mention here.
So we can probably design for
any build system.  We made some
key decisions early on that
tightly coupled us to Google's
internal build system.  But this
was a problem, even at Google,
not everyone is using Google's
internal build system, and we
were not able to host that
infrastructure with them, and
not with the community and we
could not open source it.
Similarly, we did not build some
of the tools -- some of the
tools that we built were not
cross-platform, they worked on
Linux, but not Mac and Windows.
And another thing we would do
differently, and
retrospectively, it is not a
good thing that we started out
small and scaled up our testing.
While the apps grew and the
ecosystem grew, there were more
and more requirements.  We
usually built them into the
infrastructure, but we did not
have a mechanism for teams to
customize the infrastructure.
We suffered from hide code
complexity t was hard to
maintain and some features would
thought could not be removed and
they were not used anymore.  The
other thing to mention is
configuration, the hosting
infrastructure was getting
configuration from many sources,
flags, system environment
variables and config files.
This made it hard to track down
bugs in the infrastructure
itself.  So about a year ago,
our team sat down with app teams
in Google and we wanted to learn
about the past and the future
and especially how the Android
testing landscape had changed.
And so what we came up with to
solve  solve some of the
problems out of the discussion
was project nitrogen.  It was a
new unified testing platform
that we first talked about at UI
UAT I/O this year that will ship
in 2019.  Project Nitrogen is
used by a small number of apps
in Google and we are slowly
scaling it up to some of the
bugest in the world.  The reason
we are doing this is because we
want to battle test it first
before we ship it to you.  But
the point is we want to give all
of the infrastructure that we
use to run 10 billion tests to
you.  So nitrogen solves many
problems, but two of the key
issues that we are trying to
solve with nitrogen is, first,
we want to create a unified
entry point into Android
development.  And secondly, we
want to be able to write tests
with a unified API and move them
between layers.  If you think
about Android testing today, it
looks like this you. Have.  You
have tools on the left, such as
Android studioStudio, Gradle, a
CI system, and Bazel.  On the
right, you have run times you
want to run on.  We call run
time devices on Nitrogen.  You
want to run tests on a simulated
device, or a virtual or physical
device, or on a remote device
that runs on a device lab, such
as Firebase.  And in order to do
so, we have many different entry
points, it looks like this.  You
have a configuration for every
tool, you have different roles
and tasks and it is a nightmare
to maintain.  What we see in
Google, it is so hard to move
from one to another, they would
go from one test to another.  So
what we want to do with nitrogen
is to have a unified entry
point.  And nitrogen itself is a
stand-alone binary, or tool, and
infrastructure developers can
use to customize their
infrastructure.  And obviously,
there are all of these other
developers that don't work on
infrastructure and work in
actual lab code.  We want to
provide integrations into all of
the tools on the left hand side
to make it easy to run tests.
And, at that point, if you have
a single entry point and a
unified test, it fits very well
within your developer workflow,
because you can do local, fast
iterative development on a
simulated device.  And before
you submit the change, you can
run on an emulator matrix.  And
lastly, in post-submit, you can
run on a remote device, a
physical device, in Firebase
test lab.  And that is what we
are trying to do with nitrogen.
Nitrogen allows you to run tests
at scale.
It is highly configurable, it
was build with customization and
extensibilityextensibility in
mind.  You can execute unit
tests, it improves reporting
and, therefore, debugging.  And
one of the most exciting things
is it ships with its virtual
device management solution that
manages devices for you.
And that is actually something I
think a
lot of the community has been
asking us for quite a while.  So
Nitrogen is cross-platform, and
we build it from the ground up
with all the experience that we
have, seven years in host side
in that infrastructure.  It
supports Mac, , Windows, and
Linux, and it is written in
Kotlin, and we write it in a way
that it will be viable for the
next seven years.
And
Nitrogen is a stand alone tool.
It can be integrated into any
system.  We are working on
integrations for Gradle and
basilbasil Bazel.  We are
working on test execution and
support will be there from the
start.  On the device side, we
are planning to have support for
simulated, virtual, and physical
devices, and device labs, such
as Firebase.  And you can even
add your custom devices if you
have custom hardware.
So let's switch gears a little
bit and talk a little bit about
the high level architecture of
nitrogen.  So nitrogen is
basically split into two parts:
We have a host side
infrastructure that is all the
code that runs on the host, ask
we've done something new.  We
have an on-device infrastructure
which means that we have moved
some of our infrastructure on to
the device, which is a much
saner environment to reason
about, and the device is the
main abstraction that we use in
nitrogen for different run
times.  So the host site runner
is mostly responsible for
finding the device for you,
setting up the device for test
execution, and then requesting a
test run.  It can be easily
configured with a proto buffer
configuration, and it allows you
to customize things like the
test executor and the whole test
harness.
To decouple the host from the
device, we have a new
orchestrater service.  You can
think of it as the brain
is responsible for discovery,
filtering, and sorting, and
execution.
And an orchestrater service is
just a GRPC service that can be
implemented by any device.  And
we, in fact, use GRPC to
communicate between the host and
the device, which does not give
us performance and speed.  It
gives us a lot of stability and
it allows us to stream test
results back to the host in
realtime.  We also have a lot of
extension points.  So we will
have host plugins that allow you
to run code on a host, and we
will also have device plugins
that allow you to run code on
the device.  So let's dive into
each of these sections.
As I mentioned before, we use a
single proto configuration with
a declarative set of protos.
This allows you to find devices,
the text features, so you can
find APKs that you want to
install, and it can declare your
host and device plugins.  We
initially will have support for
single device executers,
parallel device executers, to
run on multiple devices in
parallel.  And we will also have
a new multi-device executor,
which will allow you to do
things like orchestrating a test
run between a device and a
device, or a device and a watch,
which is something that we
increasingly see as a
requirement.  The good news is:
If you are just an app
developer, you don't have to
deal with any of this
configuration, because it is
built in in the tool
integration.  But if you are an
infrastructure developer, this
is where it is really
interesting for you.  Because
you can customize every single
bit of Nitrogen.
Let's talk a little bit about
plugins.
So host plugins are plugins that
can execute code on the host.
Plugins that we've already built
are the Android plugin, theythey
encapsulate all the code that
allows us to run Android tests
on the device.  We have a data
plugin that allows us to stage
data on the device, or a
descriptor plugin that allows us
to execute fixer scripts on the
device.  And you can have your
custom plugins.  Custom plugins
can have their own
configuration, and with host
plugins, you can run before the
test suite starts, and after the
test suite is finished.  The
reason we do it this way is we
want to avoid the chattyness
between the host and the device.
If you look at the after all
method, you will also get access
to the host test suite result,
which is great if you want to do
any post-processing of your test
results.  And you can submit an
added reQuestback to us if you
want to attach new artifacts to
the test suite result.  Device
plugins, on the other hand, like
the name says, are running on an
actual device, which is a much
more sane environment to reason
about.  Most of the host side
code that we use to configure
the device is moved to the
device with a device plugin.  So
plugins we have built are a
lockhead plugin, a screenshot
plugin that talks screenshots in
case the tests fail, or a
permission plugin was pretty
awesome.  You can grant and
revoke run time permissions,
which was not able before, and
you can obviously also have your
custom plugins.
So the difference from the
device plugin to host plugin is
that it runs on a device.
But this allows us to do things
like that.  We can give you a
call-back before the single test
method
is executed, and after it is
finished.  This is great, we can
avoid the chattyness between the
host and the device, and it
gives you a lot of control.  And
if you think about it, I don't
know how you set up your test
features now, but you generally
have something like add before
class, or add after class.  If
you want something reusable, you
will probably reach for a J unit
rule, or there is some things
that you can't do with these
APIs, and then you have to have
your custom runner.  And I think
the great thing about this is,
we give you a whole new way of
writing plugins that run on the
device and allow you to execute
code on it.  We will move to
execution.  As I was saying, we
move the execution to the actual
device.
And we created a whole new
orchestrater service and
protocol.
What this does, it standardizes
the communication between the
host and the device and it can
be implemented by any device,
which means if you have a custom
device, you can implement the
same protocol, and you can still
integrate with the host site
easily.  On Android, it is
implemented by the Android test
orc  orchestrater.  Once you
request the test run on the
host, it will go and discover
all the tests, apply any filters
and sorting that you want, and
then it will do either isolated
or batched test execution.
It will also call all of your
device plugins, and it will
stream results back in realtime
to the host.
So the last thing that I want to
talk about is reporting.  So
with nitrogen, we will give you
unified and consistent
reporting.  As I'm sure many of
you have seen this command at
the top, what it does is it runs
an instrumentation test from the
command line.  If you use the
dash R option, you will get an
output like this.  As you can
see, it is not very human
readablereadable, I would say,
and it is also quite chatty,
because this is just showing a
sungal test.
And this is showing a passing
test.  If it fails, the only
thing that it gives you an
addition is a stacktrace.  So
there is not really a lot of
information or actionable data
here to why the test failed.
And with nitrogen, we want to
move to something like this, a
structure data format, which
gives you access to the
properties of the test case, the
status of the test, and a list
of art  artifacts collected
during the test run.  Things
like screenshots,
video, lock, and any custom
artifacts that you run in your
post-processing.
Again, this will also be
integrated in Android Studio,
and we will surface this in the
Android Studio UI if you run
tests.
The last thing before I wrap up
what, I wanted to mention we
have support for custom reports.
You can do J unit XML, or the
custom report that integrates
better with your own
infrastructure. And with that, I
want to hand over to
Vishal who is going to talk
about device management.
[ Applause ].
SPEAKER: Running any kind of
Android UI test generally
happens on devices.  There are
two device tests where you can
run the test, the physical or
the watchful device.
Regardsless, they each have
their own sets of pros and cons.
Let's do a quick show of hands.
How many people around here have
set up something like this,
testing on physical devices? It
looks like quite a few.
So a follow-up question.  How
easy was it to manage them?
Hard.
And another follow-up question.
Did you end up using a file
testing machine next to it? I
hope not.  I have a funny story
to share that happened a few
years at Google when one of the
teams decided they wanted to
test their stuff on physical
devices.  They procured a bunch
of devices, it  glued them to
the wall, and integrated with
the CI infrastructure.
Everything was running well
until one fine day when the
engineers came back on a Monday
morning and things timed out.
If you were to guess what went
wrong, what would your guess be?
Okay, so it turned out to be an
air conditioned problem.
So what happened is the air
conditioners in the building in
San Francisco went bad, and
because the air conditioners
went back, the facilities
decided they wanted to switch
off the air conditioners so they
can fix it, but tests were
running on those devices and the
heat produced in the devices
caused the glue to peel off from
the wall and all the devices
fell to the ground.  Managing
physical devices are hard.  I
want to give a huge shout out to
the fair base test lab team that
makes testing on Firebase so
much easier for you folks. How
do we solve this at Google? The
virtual device infrastructure,
the testing environment we use
is very stable.  The number on
the right is the stability ratio
of our test environment, it is
99.9999 percent.
The continuous integration, the
virtual device infrastructure
that we use has the ability to
run locally, or in a CI
environment.  And it supports
over 500 different device
configurations.  Let's see what
is the current state at Google.
It used be over 100 first party
apps, such as Google photos,
search, YouTube, and so on.
Just in 2018, it had a
staggering 2.4 billion
invocations, that number is
growing year over year.  There
are 28,000 targets using this
infrastructure.  Having a great
infrastructure is a must for
volatile apps.  How does this
fit in with Nitrogen? If you
remember from slides presented
earlier, NIFEP  nitrogen has the
concept of device protide
viders, the virtual device
provider, which launches the
device, returns the concept back
to nitrogen and executes the
test.  Ask  once the test is
done t , it starts the device.
You get a stable environment
launched by nitrogen, runs the
test, and shuts it down.  And
while designing this
infrastructure, there are four
things that we kept in mind.
The virtual device
infrastructure needs to be
simple to use, it needs to be
extremely stable, and you should
be reproducible, regardless of
the environment running in,
locally or in the CI
infrastructure, and it needs to
be fast.  We will dig into it
deeper as to how we achieved
each of these four goals.
So the virtual device
infrastructure has a very simple
protocol configuration.  What
does that mean? It is a config
file where you can add the
characteristics of the device.
What is the horizontal scheme
resolution, the vertical screen
resolution, the memory of the
device? So for each of the
device types, like nexus and
pixel, the device management
solution has pre-baked in all of
these device configurations, you
don't have to figure out the
different resolutions for each
of these devices.  It supports
over 500 different device config
RAISHZ figerations. Because it
is a file, it is a matter of
adding or removing changes to
the configuration file.  It
has several different -- and
launching it is as simple as
calling the device binary and
specifying the name of the
device.  If you want to launch a
pixel two, device equals pucks
pixel two and the API level.
You don't have to worry about
specifying configurations and
things like that.  That makes it
very simple.
And stability, this is one of
the biggest problems most of the
Android app developers face, you
are running the test and an ANR
pops up and it might not be the
app you are testing.  We had the
same problem internally as well.
How did we solve this?
Well, sorry, Android has a nifty
service to suppress ANRs when it
sees them.  This is the same
service that Android monkey
uses.  This increases the
stability of the tests.  One
thing consider  I forgot to say,
when we started with this
infrastructure, the stability
was 95 percent.  That is no good
when you are running things at
scale.  The first thing we saw
is ANRs, once we fixed it, the
stability increased.  But not to
the level we wanted.
The next thing that we saw is
we booted up the device, but the
screen is not unlocked.  And if
the screen is not unlocked, all
the key elements that you inject
do not reach the app.  If they
don't reach the app, they are
not getting tested, and your
tests are starting to fail.  And
when the device boots up, the
screen is not locked.
So the careen is screen is not
unlocked.  And Google added an
API where you can dismiss the
key guard to unlock the screen.
So every time you call the
device, we will call to unlock
the screen.  A few years ago,
Android changed the file system
from via FFS, another file
system, to EXT4.
EXT4 was prone to discorruption
during shut down.  So if we did
not correctly shout it down, the
subsequent -- (indiscernible) --
of the device would fail,
leading to test flakyness.  How
did we solve this problem? We
called in SSH to disk image that
was unmounted, and this
guaranteed, when the disk was
unmounted, it had no diserrors,
if there are no disk errors, the
subsequent boot would come up
fine, this increased the
stability of the test
environment.  But that is no
good.  When you are running on
2.4 billion
innovations, a one-person
failure is a huge number.
There's a bunch of optimizations
we did for the stability.  I
will not talk about all of them,
but there's one final thing to
talk about.
Launch the device, it will set
up a boot saying that the device
is booted up.  But for whatever
reason, the launcher dudsdoes
not kick in.  How did we solve
that problem? We had to send out
an intent to the launcher, if it
was lost, if it wasn't launched
then we started the launcher and
we would return the control back
to nitrogen that would run the
tests.  Doing a bunch of
optimizations like this helped
us to get to 99.9999 percent
stability.  The next big pillar
we had in mind is reap
reproducibility.  In the CI
environment, if the test failed,
there is no way to debug it
locally.  So the virtual device
environment we built, we have to
make sure the environment is
reproducible regardless of what
they are running.  So the
management solution helps you to
run things locally or on the
cloud.  And one of the big
things about this environment is
the device starts in a clean,
pristine state.  So there is no
state carried forward with
different invocations, making
sure the state is stable and not
failed because of the device
itself.  Android Shell.  There
are several teams within Google
that indicate when you are
writing native code.  To test
the native code, we wanted to
boot up on devices.  And booting
up on devices were slow.  On
nougat, it takes 10 minutes.
And this is slowing it down
tremendously.  This made us go
back to the drawing board to see
what can we do to decrease the
time it takes to boot up
those devices.
So we ended up going and
creating a miniboot mode in
virtual device.  What does
miniboot mode mean? You don't
need the Android stack to be up
and running, you need the Linux
kernel, if it is up and running,
you can test the native APIs.
We added it to the device
launcher, comes up in less than
30 seconds, allowing them to
test the native code quickly.
Because we were running things
at scale, we were looking at
where we were spenting our time.
25 percent of the time was spent
booting up the emulator,
installing the app, and 20
percent of the time was spent in
running the test itself.
Android made a change between
lollipop and
nuugat, they wanted an error at
time compilation.
And because the stacks were so
huge, we ended up -- you have
the same device and ach on the
test that is being tested and
the same Dex2O at every session.
What if we moved this as a
single action on the Bazel bell
graph and reused the old file
that was generated for the test
runs? This reduced the install
time from 3 minutes to under a
minute.
When the emulator team presented
about snapshots, you can boot it
up, and shut it down, when you
restart it, it restarts back
from the same state.  We
integrated the snap shot feature
into virtual device launcher,
you boot it up, take a snap
shot, shut it down and reuse it
when the test runs. This reduced
test run times by 30 percent.
When you run tests at 2.4
invocations, it yields a huge
number of -- you save huge
amounts of CPU resources.
One of the other features
we wanted to work next year is
snapshots.
And this, we come to the end of
the talk, with nitrogen, you can
run the test at scale in a
completely stable environment
with the different pillars. This
is the stabilization platform to
help you test.  In this talk, we
did a lot of technical stuff
like activity controller, you
don't have to worry about all of
those things, they are
incorporated in Nitrogen and the
virtual device management
solution, you just have to use
this.
So we are hoping to release
nitrogen alpha in Q1 of next
year, and the virtual device
management solution is going to
be released the same time as
well.  Firebase test lab is
actually integrating with
nitrogen as well to run your
tests.  And one of the things
that Steven pointed out earlier
about integration with Android
Studio, imagine you are sitting
in Android Studio, you launch
the device from there  the tests
and it give gives you the
results.
That's it.  Thank you very
much.
[ Applause ].
SPEAKER: Well, hey, everyone.
I wanted to thank you all for
coming and attending the Android
Dev Summit.  It is really,
really amazing to do this again.
We want to know what you think,
this is really important.  All
of you will get a survey in your
inbox.  Please fill it out,
because it is -- we so much want
to make this event amazing,
should we ever do it again, we
really want to know what worked
and didn't work, what you liked,
didn't like.  And the second
thing is, we are going to -- we
have these QR codes that we can
put up one more time hopefully.
And these are how you rate the
sessions.  We want to know what
sessions you loved, what
sessions you liked, what
sessions you sat through because
they were there in the same room
and you were kind of comfort
comfortable in your seat.
Please fill out the surveys, I
know it is a lot of work, but we
appreciate  appreciate that.  If
you miss anything, all of the
talks are up right
now on the Android developer's
YouTube channel.  From yesterday
and most of them from today are
already going up.  And by the
end of tonight, all of them are
on the channel.  You can go home
tonight, if you have not enough
Android Dev Summit by now, you
can have more from the comfort
of your very own history museum.
And finally, we have a little
bit of a final reel here of some
of what was going on here that
we should share to you as you
think about wandering out here
and going back to the real
world.  So thank you so much for
coming again.
[ Applause ]